Absolutely not.
Never washed it.
Anybody know it?
Let me know where we live that we're actually live.
We're on the air right now.
Eddie Bravo is here.
Is You Brah.
Hello?
Brian Mother.
Yes,
I am.
And Brendan,
sharpest.
Perfect terrier.
I fucked up but too much Steven in the coffee though.
Oh yeah.
You just take this one and uh,
I trust your spit.
I hope you don't have herpes and just go back and forth with mine because
there's none in there.
And then we'll,
we'll make a concoction both for the both of us,
Bro.
Split up a concoction.
Just do it.
You're a scientist.
You could snort Stevia.
Yeah,
you can't if that dude.
Yeah.
And remember Diego Sanchez got really into that for awhile with Dan Quinn as
Diego Sanchez got really into Dang Quinn's Stevia thing.
Like he was going to melt fat with Stevia and cure cancer and go to the moon.
Just a guy out there.
His name was Dan Quinn,
who believes that Stevia can change the world.
Tell me how that big brown
companion chocolatey Mankous hell yeah.
All right.
So I'm going for taste like a chocolate.
He man,
mankind that if you're listening to this podcast,
we're watching the fights live from Germany.
They play at noon in La.
So we all got out of our comfy beds and beautiful wives arms and embraces and
came here to watch dudes fight.
We're not going to be watching the fights.
You want to know what happened?
We don't know better.
We'll be talking about subjects that belong in a 14 year olds,
treehouse.
That's essentially what we talk about.
Yeah.
The other thing about muscles did,
Greg might eventually get to some of these fights.
I want to talk about a liter Latifa and uh,
Ryan Bader.
When that fight happens,
tough fight.
That dude,
that dude scaries fuck that.
Latifa can bomb.
He can throw some punches and he's a tank because it has been known to eat a
couple.
That's,
that's it's just,
it does nothing for bait or either.
Yeah.
But baiters fought well against certain guys that are like powerful,
scary guys.
He just really fucked up against rumble.
But you're looking at that to bet against him.
He just made a giant mirror.
Yeah.
You can't blame.
I mean she,
what rumble just did the glow over that low like weird.
He had the ankle pickled pig
brains and I think he just took a chance at something weird.
Like hoping maybe it would work out.
Can't do.
I think you also maybe like had a moment,
you know in there.
Oh Shit.
Oh yeah,
that's not James.
Tony don't do the same game plan Randy couture had against James.
Anthony Johnson went ha punch him right in the face.
Not only that,
he controlled him on the ground till he punched him in the face and eventually
got them flatten down on his,
on his stomach.
He just stepped up with.
That might be the worst place in the world to be flattened out on your stomach
underneath rumble Johnson.
There is,
there is a,
uh,
like that's probably,
that is the worst place.
That's right next to that dude.
Got His arm trapped in the Rock and how to saw it off.
Yeah.
And also
in a small crocodiles that's worse or standing right in front of him like
clover.
Oh God.
Well glue over.
Just try to put that pressure on him.
Hey Man,
dude,
you can't walk forward.
You just see an upper cut.
Do you remember that?
Do you remember that white supremist where they had his brother in jail and in
protest.
He videotaped himself,
sawing his home,
his own handoff.
So hit.
Yup.
He had a camera on and he goes,
I want to show you guys something.
Essentially basically showing them that he,
that they had no control of him,
that he,
his mind was stronger than us
and just cut his own hand off.
Would you like to go with that same premise?
Jamie,
pull that up.
I need to see this.
Yeah.
My cousin brother ended up for me.
I feel like,
uh,
talk off off the air.
I want to send them Marcin held and a tay young bang t hung bay is from Korea.
He's a Korean cowboy.
He said Marcin held a lot of adolescent girl.
I'm sorry,
Nick Heine.
You know what Marcin held?
Just got signed.
I was up.
I was actually going to bring that up.
These jugs just got signed over from Bella tour.
Very hesitant here ladies.
And he's a really good foot lock guy.
Hug leg lock really,
really good.
Yeah.
I don't know why I confuse all white people.
I think all white people look the same.
They too.
Especially for athletes,
super racist when it comes to white people,
the whites to the whites,
white people from other countries where they talk word all the same.
Yeah.
That that can never be racist.
White people look the
be trouble.
Even Mexicans.
Yup.
A black person could say white people look the same to me on TV and nobody gives
a shit.
Not Exactly.
Exactly.
You'd have to be like,
you'd have to be really,
really funny and it'd have to be a really obvious joke for you to use any other
race if you were,
especially if you were white guy.
Sam.
Sam Probably has that joke where he goes,
he'll say,
he'll be like,
um,
I lost Bobby Lee and to Korean day parade.
You ever lose a Korean Korean and a Korean parade?
It's like looking for a needle in a needle stack.
Come on.
That's fine.
It was funny and it is true to this certain,
sir,
I'm not going to say it's true,
but I am saying it's funny,
there's certain races that it's share so many similarities like as far as like
their uh,
their mannerisms or their,
um,
their features and stuff.
I mean it's,
there's so much variety in like America,
right?
Because we come from so many different parts of the world mixing.
You thought of us as a country,
which,
you know,
we are a country but we're not a country.
Like,
like say if you wanted to go and meet some Colombians you were in Colombia,
most of them are going to look like Columbia.
You know what I mean?
They have a very distinct look to them,
especially the women baby.
Well,
China,
very much like China with the,
I think in China to have that many people speaking mandarin,
which had to do,
I think with the Yangzi and the Yellow River,
we could,
they could trade and,
and you know,
ideas.
And so it,
and plus I think they were pretty isolated.
So you're right,
there wasn't as much,
you know,
immigration and mixed that United States.
I mean,
everybody's fucking,
everybody not only done,
it's never been like this before where there's 300 million people when we,
we vary so much and were more varied now than ever before.
Like they say,
what is it like that,
I think they said 20 more years and white people are going to be a minority.
It's fascinating.
Yeah.
It's just the Chinese and already can say Asian and Mexicans will be the
minority in America.
Correct.
Well,
China's film market is neck and neck with the United States now,
cause I mean China's expendables 19 nope.
They're making their own movies and they're building huge movie studios also
using our old like special own such a hit now over there.
Like they just found him.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Well it's just,
it's interesting man.
It's interesting that this world is sort of,
it's in some places it's not sort of meshing with the,
with everything else,
but in most places people are spreading out and sort of like integrating with
each other.
I remember when I was little,
my dad gets,
so I was like four or five and we'd see an Asian person.
I'd say,
Oh look at that Chinese got,
you know it's something I'd say some shit.
He's like,
he's not Korean.
I'm fucking five man.
That's what I do.
Can't tell the difference between the eyes.
I do.
Dad got mad at you it that when you were five.
Even today,
even today he's from Korea and day.
Maybe it should make sense like you should learn to my man.
It's tough.
I've never been over there.
Like I can tell a difference between like a Korean,
a Japanese person now my favorite number.
So my favorite thing to do is take clothes.
Yeah.
I love drawing a distinction and alerting people to the fact that I know the
difference and then I'll give you a little history lesson on it.
Yeah,
you did.
I walk away feeling good about my city to do.
Greg Fitzsimmons does this thing on his,
in his show where he guesses the Asian calls,
a guest,
the Asian.
He's hard to people.
God bless him.
He's really good at it.
I bet if you're,
if you can tell the difference,
he can pick up.
He tells differentiating Philippinos and people from Bali.
I think that's easy.
They're huge difference.
I think that's a skill my man took an x men power.
No,
if you're in America,
it is.
You know what's weird is like that America has only been around for like really
a few hundred years from the first settlers,
right?
First European settlers,
40 or something.
Yeah.
And then before that,
just one look,
right?
Like native American.
And then in that time,
like just the change of the landscape has been so drastic and just a short
amount of time.
You think about any other time in the world,
any other part of the world,
some someplace as big as the continental United States just gets transformed
over a couple hundred years and just want paypal.
Just fail
shit over.
What about Israel?
And that like,
wizards wrote small,
you know,
Israel's 10th,
1948 and it's a tiny place and they still look like all the people that hate
another deal.
I used to have that bit.
Remember that there's,
there's,
there's uh,
Brown skin dude with dark curlier hair throwing rocks at a brown skin dude with
dark
curly hair holding a machine gun.
I go,
what's going on?
How do you guys look exactly like the Chinese words that
tennis match between the Williams sisters?
Who the fuck is zoo?
What's he going crazy or what's even crazier?
They believe in the same God.
They believe in the same God and basically the Koran says that everything in
the,
in the Old Testament is true.
So even the grand says that's the first book.
Then they had a problem with the new testament,
but it's kind of wild.
Sure.
Figure it out.
It's just territory.
Territory.
Well there's no way you going to figure it out cause you want to make your
parents happy and you know they have a set of rules and you grew up with them
and you start raising your kid that way.
And then those all those ancient ideas about who those people that you don't
know our versus these people next to you that you don't know.
Well,
these people were on my side of the dirt and those people are and that side of
the door and we believe a certain type of wacky shit and they believe it's a
different type of work.
He Shit,
I mean they have their problems over there,
but we have prompts here to like,
have you seen how the Kaepernick situation escalated?
Yes.
In that.
Explain that to me.
So,
so Kaepernick won't stand for like explain who he is.
Uh,
Colin Kaepernick is uh,
the starting quarterback for the San Francisco 40 niners.
He's African American and mixed with something else.
So he's lighter skinned and he was adopted.
He was raised by white parents and so he was a big time core back playing like
shit lately.
But he was a big time quarterback.
Refuses to stand for the national anthem because says is people are pressed and
the cop treatment,
stuff like that.
And then a picture came out that he wore them a while ago.
These socks with a cops has pigs on him.
You want him to practice a while ago before he made this stance.
And so that's,
that photo had been brought back out.
So now the cops in Santa Clara are saying,
we're not working the games anymore unless you guys do some about Kapnik we're
not working in the games anymore.
So the cops were taking a protest now,
which to me is like,
it's definitely not the right thing to do cause he has freedom of speech,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
first amendment he can do that whether you agree with it or not,
but the cops like now you've got your sinking,
his left,
you're going to be vague,
big nutrition to not do your job because you don't like a guy's opinion.
Cops or cops I work games are off duty police officers.
That's a good point.
So they're doing it,
they're doing it for extra money.
It's kind of like they're just doing it cause you know,
they,
they enjoy the game and they want to keep the fucking San Francisco 40 another
shape.
Well they're going to exercise their right and then the is going to exercise his
right and somewhere in the middle something's got to have to complete nightmare
though.
It's not good.
You know,
it's not a good,
it's not a smart platform for all this because I agree it's all going to get
lost in the noise is a real point.
If he has a real point about what he doesn't like about the way the United
States is going or the way our country is being led [inaudible] that's not,
it gets a lot of people paying attention,
but it's just going to get a lot of hate.
But it does nothing like you're not changing anything by not standing for the
anthem during the national football.
He liked the cops still going to be the cops and the black girls still me a
press.
You're really not changing all these starting the dialogue he thinks and when
you're young and you know and you have a strong ego and you feel like you're in
a position of quote unquote leadership,
you feel like you can,
you can make a stand.
It's a clumsy,
maybe a little clumsy on his pipe clamps,
but now you have other players don't do the same thing.
What he wanted though.
Why would he say all that?
He wants this mission accomplished.
Well,
it's not working because everyone's talking about,
well,
but they'd be realized it was going to be like this.
Well,
I think he kinda did,
but the big issue is he's just not playing very good at football.
So now the niners if they release them,
they're going to get so much flack.
Oh,
that's fucking racist because this,
no,
no.
He just kept on fucking football and I bet they won't.
I bet they won't.
I bet the tougher thing will be him getting picked up by somebody else.
Like what team wants to take on that PR nightmare.
True.
You know,
and meet,
you're going to,
you're going to risk the,
the,
the ire of all the police unions that are working your games,
you know,
and all the people in your town,
they're going to say,
oh,
what was,
this is what our team's all about.
We're about taking this guy in.
What if you went to more African American market like Atlanta,
Philadelphia,
you don't do it.
But he'd be,
I wonder if most African Americans see when you don't stand for the national
anthem,
which is,
you know,
the United States versus government or government or a government policy.
Those things can be separate.
I the,
yeah,
he says that.
He says so now instead of just sitting on the bench,
he takes a knee because he goes,
I'm not doing this against the soldiers that I have friends.
My uncle was in the military,
so now it takes a knee and had a like former navy seal and next to him and
hugged him after he goes,
I'm doing it because the way that I made out.
Yeah,
that'd been dope.
He's just trying to make just a shit to this for gays as well,
just over the top for everybody.
He's trying to bring attention to something he felt strongly about.
And the question is,
is it,
like you said,
the best venue,
well,
it's,
maybe it's talking about getting people talking about it.
Obviously you want it to be loud about it and this is loud as fuck.
Even grew up powerful Afro,
I think he loves it.
Powerful Afro.
Maybe.
I think it's tough,
right?
Well,
yeah,
that's the thing.
Like if you,
you got to be playing real well to have a fucked up opinion.
Tom Brady.
Well cool man.
Yeah Dude.
Your thing with him,
it's like fuck,
he's not even the starter probably and he's going to be paid $19 million this
year.
So that might have a little bit to do with him getting cut to,
that's what I'm saying is contracting is unfilled plays the bigger issue.
If,
if you're calling,
that's a tremendous amount of money.
A lot of money.
He signed $114 million contract to Lord.
What?
Brendan,
when he,
when if at a 19 million after agents and taxes,
what do you think he sees?
I mean,
19 millions.
That's his guarantee signing bonus.
Right?
So agents take 10% and the taxes,
I mean he,
he sees a shitload of money and he's about 10 mil,
but maybe,
no,
because you're to,
you got figure it out.
These probably in the 48% tax bracket.
It's probably as a manager,
an agent and a lawyer.
And there's a lot of ships.
He's about distributed,
but don't get it twisted.
He awesome.
This is just part of the contract.
He's rich as fuck.
Cause he had,
this is this third contract or second is second.
So before that he's already making money.
Was He better before was you had to play everything.
He took him to the,
to the conference finals and the playoffs,
you know.
So when did it start going bad for him?
From,
from my insiders who actually someone worked for San Francisco 40 niners they
were saying it,
it really went bad for him because he was like a really athletic quarterback and
no one could really pick up his style of play.
And once they figured it out,
he was a guy who was on social media all the time and he got all the negativity
got to him.
So he was,
he's a sensitive dude and just all the critique and from the media and everyone
else really got to them.
So He's lost weight.
He's changed his stolen motion.
He doesn't run anymore is he's all because the hour now,
social media fucked with them.
They're saying that that's just just this wave.
Like you let the criticism get to them.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
The haters right now are going,
why the trolls?
We got 'em he starts $19 million people.
Yeah,
but if he's losing weight and feel nervous,
they win 100% yeah.
Losing weight.
How old is he?
He might be 26
how old is Jamie?
26 there is so much money on your shit.
Nevada twice.
First of all,
asking a 26 year old 20th stance about global issues.
Why?
While they're in the middle of a professional athletic career,
lot at the highest level,
which demands,
you know as much as anybody.
If you're playing professional football,
tell us how much fucking that demands of your day.
There's a course,
especially as a quarterback,
you're the man of your day.
Oh Man.
In season,
I mean
you're talking full time.
I mean nine to five doesn't count.
You've talked about endless hours of studying practice.
You're the leader of the strength and conditioning drills.
Plyo.
Those video.
Lee really learn the film room more than anyone.
Breakdown tape and how tired are you?
All the time.
I'm exhausted.
Exhausted.
Especially a guy like that who he relies on his athleticism and get the place
done,
but then it fell.
Felt doesn't work like that.
You have to use your brain at the passport.
How many players per team would you say?
Cause they have a book,
right?
I mean you're talking thousands,
thousands of plants that they have to now.
Yes.
To know the whole doesn't have time to be studying global issues.
No.
That's why.
That's why he's playing like shit.
It'd be way more powerful if he played well was a starter,
started winning games and then came out and did this maybe after the season two
there's no 26 year olds.
It's built to handle the kind of pressure that comes being that famous in a big
football player and then on top of that supporting some sort of a global issue
like some,
some sort of a national issue on,
on the United States,
like the state of the United States,
you're going to make an official state managing.
It's putting up,
putting a lot on your plate.
I know I shouldn't be making an official statement today and I'm almost
not ready yet.
I'm back.
I can't imagine what he's dealing with the Haiti.
I'm sure it is,
you know,
support from a lot of people,
but a lot of it is a lot of,
it's negative.
Then you've got to get ready for a football game.
It's make or break.
I played poorly.
It's going to get,
it's going to get negative real quick and from all sides,
right?
I mean,
yeah.
No,
I don't think from all sides.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
African American people are pretty proud of them and certain aspect,
well,
some people proud of them too,
that feel like things aren't the way they should be in this country.
And at least this guy used that platform and took a chance.
Correct.
But I think you're dead right.
And that the real problem is you got to be playing really fucking good to pull
something like that off.
Like people don't want to just listen to you.
If you're,
you're ruining and you're going to go,
me is going to be so much pressure on him every time he does Pli,
it's people are going to be psyched if he gets nailed.
Yeah.
What's,
what's the pressure?
I mean,
he watches a couple of youtube videos and I mean,
there's not like something that he's got to study it or socks.
So what,
what is he doing?
You know what you mean?
Tweet.
He has the entire San Francisco 40 niners organization on his back to win games.
And if he doesn't perform the,
he's gonna lose his job.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a tough game.
It's a tough Gig,
man.
You don't feel bad about them any?
No,
but he's got money because he's black ridges.
Shit,
super famous and he wants this attention.
Why else would he wear those socks if Tom Brady wore those socks?
The whole arena would be yelling.
Fuck the police.
Right.
Tom Brady's white though.
Exactly.
He's today though.
I think they would turn on him or thing.
They turn it down.
Tom Brady,
you just bullshit.
You can't do anything wrong.
He would turn on him.
England wouldn't murder someone and they'd be like,
yeah,
what can you do it like even with us,
tell us the whole story.
And he did murder.
Well probably lift off.
You know like even with her and Hernandez,
the guy who's a straight up murder,
they were like,
I mean if he gets out,
we'll take him.
He's such a good player.
We were was like,
I mean,
we wouldn't be mad if he gets,
he's such a good player.
They just want to win fucking football games in New England.
That's how good of a place where I went to the murderer.
You know what the Patriots might sell you for saying that they'd probably agree
with you now that I can see how it goes.
I'm trying to win games here.
Jesus Christ.
Neil Brennan has a fucking hilarious bit about football and I can't do it
without doing it.
You know,
I can't like give you like the premise of it is talking about why football
players do fucked up shit.
It is hilarious.
He's my favorite guest on your podcast.
Is He really by far?
I think he's the most creative fucking he's,
I've never met him in person,
but dude,
he's great.
That's brilliant.
Very,
very smart.
So creative.
Get them in the fighter and the kid.
Yeah,
you guys love him.
He's awesome.
God,
he's talented.
So talented.
There was football,
but he did last night.
I was crying.
Really crying.
Okay.
I can't do it because it'll give away the bit,
but it's very,
very old.
I finally watched the roast with Jim Ross with a big boy.
What's his name?
The,
the,
a big fat Guy Ralphie may be for his feelings got hurt.
I heard it was bad.
Dude.
I can't watch.
I mean,
he got a,
it's a roast battle,
Ralph,
he's going through a divorce and these people just fucking dope that the fucking
hammer and recall coffin.
The guy goes,
well,
you've lost your,
had itself like that.
You've lost your wife,
your career.
You can't sell tickets.
You've,
you know,
you've lost everything.
Only thing you have.
It lost his weight motherfucker.
And it was like,
Oh,
I like that style because he,
he set us just all rose though.
Don't get involved in it.
She wears those Ding Ralphie may,
it was a,
Ralphie may wrote what I wrote,
John Roast each other years.
He roast battle and so hilarious show.
Yeah.
They have it at the comedy store.
You've got to come.
And I love it.
They do it at the comedy store on Tuesday nights and they do it late at night.
And uh,
I think it starts at like midnight,
right?
I'm not sure,
isn't it?
But your boy Tony Hinchcliffe tore it up too.
It's just some of the funniest young up and coming kids and just adults,
I should say.
Some of them are like for whatever reason,
deepen their thirties there's some people,
some 50 year old people that are on roads battle.
They have great judges to yeah,
and they have comics judge it and then they'll,
they'll do like one,
you know,
one joke and the other person will do it in a joke against them and they go back
and forth and then the audience decides who got who better.
It's so creative and like Tony Hinchcliffe,
I guess he,
he does a podcast at the comedy store on Monday nights or something like that,
whatever it is.
And he texts me and goes,
cop killed Tony Killed Tony.
Yeah.
He texted me his,
hey man,
when he come by and do the podcast,
and I went,
oh no,
do the show.
And when I'm down to do like a podcast,
but I'm not letting you just roast the shit out of me.
It's to how to come.
I'm not good at roasting other people.
Like I'm not good at those comebacks.
I also,
you want everybody to love you.
You don't want to be mean to be on to hurt anybody's feelings for you.
Be it after you are.
Tony would eat you.
I can't.
I can't help people.
Even if I had a good tape put I put down,
I couldn't tell it was Tony would eat you
like a cannibal.
Brian Moses,
the guy who hosts it is perfect.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
It's a great show.
You know?
It's tough on that because obviously they're,
they're going based off each other.
You volleying back and forth telling jokes and roasting each other,
but when someone has a horrible,
you're like just a great roast and the other one's not ready there.
When it,
when a roast is bad,
it's bad.
That's why your,
your eyes are close together and the crowds like,
it's just dead silent.
I'm like,
Oh God.
I heard,
come watch it.
Get knocked outside.
I don't like to come.
He Central,
I'm sure it's on Youtube,
but Whoopi Goldberg was a coaching or she was a judge.
Man.
It was tough.
What was tough?
Whoopi Goldberg,
her commentary and everything.
Like she just,
she just out of the loop,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
She's a grandma and the mic.
That's 100% where she was doing.
It's funny how people can ride something great for a long time.
Like her first HBO special with Pretty,
was it really great.
Yeah,
it was really good.
Really,
really good theatrically.
It was excellent.
This mother fuckers an audition again.
He's great.
All right.
Now with the producer while last night in Santa Monica with some good friends
and not take away from Brian's trying to get on the view right now.
The two things she did to get herself known on Hbo,
they were pretty amazing.
We'll be gold,
but yeah,
you can't take that away from her.
But I will say that then she did ghost,
but you can ride that shit for a long time.
Blacking out right now.
There's no air in this room
20 years ago it 20 years ago.
She's not doing,
she's not like in the comedy scene.
She does.
She's got a look that's very distinctive and she seems like a very friendly
person in America.
Took around a long time ago and she's sort of been in this steady coasting state
ever since then.
Well,
so when she goes and does something that demands like pop,
like these things,
or when she expresses herself on the view,
she's got an opinion.
It's not very succinct.
It's not like clear and sharp and like,
like well defined.
There's like a lot,
there's a lot of like laziness to it,
you know?
And it's not that,
I'm sure she's just a really wealthy woman who is,
you know,
set for life.
She doesn't have to worry about shit.
She dressed in that way too.
And when she's up there,
she's like casual and she's being herself so essential as fuck.
Just crocs on in some ways it's like you will,
you will,
you you're getting is when you get a person that's like at that level,
she's an Oscar winner.
Yeah,
she's over it.
She's like,
what's up?
I'm going to be [inaudible] have to do,
she even brought that up in the show.
She said,
I have Oscars.
I was like,
that's what she said was a roast.
But yeah,
when someone came at her,
when her and Jelinek we're going at it and she was like,
who are you?
You know I have Oscars like that's her thing.
Like she says I have Oscars.
That's not fun.
You know what happens to it.
But that's what you'd been known.
Sometimes success can stop a lot of things.
So Bob Dylan was,
and he's produced a lot and been amazing,
but they were going through like the lyrics that he was writing and stuff and
when he was younger that made him like a legend and he said,
and he literally went and that's something.
And they go,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I just don't that that was a different person back then who wrote that stuff.
Like I could never do that again.
Can never replicate that again.
That magic that made me what I,
I am is gone.
So much of it was wanting to be heard so badly,
so much was can I even do this?
The wonder and the mystery of who am I and let me see if this African bear fruit
and when you get really wealthy and you get really famous and you become a
legend,
it's very difficult to replicate that kinds of like Alan generous for me when
she was younger and doing standup.
Personally,
I love their stand up when she was younger and then I was thinking to myself,
you did,
you had this great Santa Queer and then you became a talk show host.
You make a fortune is really good at that,
but I just could never do that.
That would be so boring to me.
Can you come to Harrison?
She's nice interview with her.
Her and Caitlin Jenner or Caitlyn Jenner was talking about how she doesn't
believe in gay marriage because there are more,
I'm more of a traditional lost,
so she's sitting there with a frozen face,
warfarin spreading.
Know
what the fuck are you talking about?
Your FYS botox to cut and your jaws jaws missing.
You're wearing lipstick,
there's all this.
That's where a up there on the screen now.
All this craziness and she's saying that she's not in the gay marriage where she
wasn't in a gay marriage.
She's trying to change my partner now,
but because she's more of a traditionalist like you are,
a man thinks they're a woman.
There's nothing further from a traditionalist
insanity.
But Ellen Reich wrote her on it.
She's like,
how?
How can someone like you,
who's like,
it was faced so much discrimination?
How could you be against gay marriage?
And this is what my,
my taking this Caitlyn Jenner thing that everybody's always been missing.
You're talking about a nonsense person.
You're talking about a male car dash.
Correct.
This is what this is.
And we're having this national debate,
which is an important national debate because there's a spectrum of gender and
there's some people that get stuck at some weird spots until like be mean about
those people because they're not a manly man like Brendan shop or a brand
council pride count or a girly girl,
you know,
like,
uh,
you know,
Katy Perry,
there's a lot of women and men that fall in these weird places.
But this is the wrong one to pay attention to.
Yes.
This is crazy.
I agree 100% this is,
I mean,
it's not a bad person,
you know,
they're not a horrible person.
She just go dashing.
Yeah.
But it's,
this is like,
this is what we've been dealing with when we're talking about like putting focus
on people for no reason whatsoever other than the fact that his camera on the
people also get bullied into being super supportive and a completely a fanatic
on that side instead of having an objective fair,
critical point of view.
Like it's weird.
Or like,
man,
and now she's not that impressive.
What you did in 1976 was pretty impressive.
And whenever,
but so it's social media,
man,
social media,
the,
the pressure and the amount of human beings that you're communicating with.
It's off the charts.
The numbers are crazy.
The numbers that you are,
you're interacting with on a daily basis.
If you have any sort of a point whatsoever,
like this football player dude,
if he has any sort of at a point that he wants to make,
dude,
you're,
you're dealing with literally millions of people throwing their opinions your
way and it's a storm and you can't,
you can't like go outside in the rain and pick the rain drop that you're going
to communicate with essentially what he's doing when its opinions,
opinions are coming at him like rain.
Well,
but also look at hunger.
Who's the comedian from Ghostbusters?
The black girl chose these Jones.
She,
her shit got so bad.
Oh,
when she,
she goes acerbated that exacerbated by about naked.
No,
no,
no.
That was afterwards.
Yeah,
I know before went ham.
I don't know if it's the same people.
I mean,
obviously somebody leaked her naked photos,
but they'll leak your naked photos too if you leave them on iCloud.
Stupid.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
They'll only everyone's naked photos.
You leave a dick on iCloud.
That shit.
All my Dick Pics are,
I'm pretty proud of that.
She interacted with some of those people and she did.
It came,
it was poorly thought out the warrant and then this guy that she's new to it too
though,
right?
Yeah,
she is new to it.
It's the most fuss sideways rain baby cause a fucking hurricane out your door.
Go out there and find a raindrop,
but I feel like successful people don't pay attention to.
Most of that's bullshit.
Some people do.
Tyron Woodley apparently has been paying attention to it.
I've been reading on the shit about Tyron reading all these haters,
tweets and always people that be,
I don't know man.
Maybe someone needs talked to him.
Maybe he doesn't mind.
Maybe he zoomed in as a psychological exercise,
but he's talking to all these people that are being racist to him.
He needs to focus on Wonderboy.
Not only that,
when you find out when they find out that you'll,
you're paying attention on its word freaks you out like this cabarnet guy and is
losing weight and he'd fucking can't throw around anymore.
Just too many of them.
Man.
It's too many people,
especially in negative and that can affect the celebrity in that fashion.
Also fucking tribe.
It's natural.
It's as natural as a virus natural at.
Yeah.
There's a certain amount of people that they got a fucking shit hand in life and
they are who they are through a series of bad decisions and life circumstances
and genetics and all the above.
And they see a guy like Kaepernick that's making 50 million bucks over the next
couple of years
and they can do to,
has a bit of a nose but good looking dude.
And they come home every day and they run to that computer from their Mcdonald's
job with the fucking fry smell over there by their hands and they just start
praying all kinds of rude shit about,
hey buddy,
you get,
oh,
the article we read,
a Time magazine had a front page article and according to that off author in his
research,
a lot of that hate comes from,
oh,
I don't know,
kindergarten teachers,
doctors,
lawyers and people.
Your next door neighbor,
you would never imagine,
but they just have a mean streak.
Well,
they just said just one free.
They said it could come from anyone.
Like they'll just don't assume the guys in the basement of his mom's house
jacking off.
Right.
I can literally come from anyone,
especially tapping it cause the San Francisco 49,
you might be a Seattle Fan.
You're like,
damn,
I'm going to hate it.
I might as well.
Right.
Have a doctor in Seattle.
Fuck this dude.
But gives you a free pass to the three pillars if another state,
because it was something about some people when nobody's looking to do something
outrageous,
forbidden.
Uh,
that would be totally out of character.
It's freeing,
right,
so they just want to do like,
it's almost like when you go,
when you're in a really in,
you're in an airplane,
you have to be quiet and seven you go to the bathroom and you're about to pay
and you look in the mirror and you go and you just do some weird face cause his
ass,
he's fucking weird.
I maybe guys,
I don't know.
No,
you're definitely right.
Like I think people that are buttoned down all day,
like doctors and lawyers and people that have to put on a persona all day long,
those are the ones who want to hire Mr says and get them to shit on them and
smack them in the face when they don't do wacky stuff.
They've done a lot of studies on cultures that produce a lot of like shit videos
and these really perverse videos talking about the Japanese,
the Japanese and the Germans who tend to be very disciplined,
very authoritarian and very buttoned down in formal.
Well listen man,
when you got to do it all the time,
I can't lock them up.
Throw up.
He wants some extreme human beings.
Will they just want to be,
it was like they were talking about why would the row,
the Germans at one point,
who would the quote unquote most civilized side in the world,
they read Girtha and everything else.
And they had,
and what happened?
It culminated with concentration camps and feeding people the gas chambers and
ovens.
Huh?
What,
what the fuck?
Meanwhile,
Alere Latifa is stepping towards a cage.
It's a video of him online really recently where he dead lifts.
What was it like 450 pounds,
33 times the temperature.
Scott Brennan.
Sean might not be able to do that.
Something ridiculous like that,
but he does 33 dead lifts with it for you watching your spark plug.
Check this motherfucker out.
Like what is the weight,
what does it say?
There were 40 33 times.
We'll get 440 pounds.
He does it.
33 fucking reps.
Um,
Mister mister jobs doing five 50 for 10 and do intense sets of that.
I could probably get close to,
I blow my ass.
I bet you could.
Is a big Oh dude.
Oh,
he's not doing,
continue doing them and then dropping them and then letting them go rent a shop.
We'll do that.
No.
Let me ask you this.
Is that the way the way to go with dead lifts?
Do you just let it go when it goes to d,
you don't lower it down?
Like why wouldn't you lower it down?
Yeah,
I lower it down.
Especially if I'm doing continuous reps.
That's a little weird.
I guess maybe saving energy joint,
but you're restarting every time so it's more work.
I feel like,
well maybe that's why they're doing it.
Maybe it's just,
I mean obviously something thought up.
I thought he was going,
oh no,
he's letting it drop.
It's still impressive.
Not as passive.
He's doing that 33 Reps.
Bp was doing,
Brennan was doing five 50 don't call him Reps.
Don't call me.
He was doing 10 reps.
Sorry.
He was doing 10 reps and he did 10 sets that,
and you were doing that.
You were lifting five 50 like you were getting out of a chair that was de cure
last for for what?
Cause I fucking tell Dick Jokes and drink coffee and strong cause you want to
look good.
Very strong.
Correct.
Yeah.
You want to look like a stud.
This guy,
this guy was like,
you're very strong,
big ass gorilla body and you weren't lifting weights.
So it'd be rude.
Like you've got this big ass body and you let it get all doughy and soft and get
a little pot that hangs over you.
Funny.
No,
no.
It's funny.
People would be upset.
This motherfucker got the perfect frame and he's wasting it.
Cheetos,
you know,
I mean if you have one of those bodies,
you're supposed to fucking maintain that bitch.
So if you have a Ferrari and you'd putting paint like audio paint,
move smartly.
Yeah,
put bumper stickers free to bet on a Ferrari.
I'm free until
I told him that.
Really funny.
You're ruining the shape of this beautiful thing.
Ryan Bader stepping in now.
How does one,
you know,
like recover from that,
um,
that rumble Johnson fight.
Like he's moving into the top 10.
He's in the top 10.
Top 12.
Yeah.
One five hours.
Way Towards a title shot.
And then he fights someone like rumble and he gets so annihilated that it leaves
this like,
okay,
how much,
how much improvement would he have to make before he could beat rumble?
Well,
but that,
that,
that rumble fight,
I don't think if I'm Ryan Beetham
his camp,
you can't really chalk it up as a,
he was the better fighter.
I think Beta shit,
his pants in a huge situation.
It didn't go his way back to the drawing board to get past this one.
Then you're pro,
he's writing to get gusts and next if they both win is what I would assume.
Maybe it could be because you know t stone Lomex to Beto Ospi.
Yeah,
he did.
But OSP,
I'm sure with Michael a rematch.
Yeah,
it'd be tough.
It'd be Tommy 33 near laser.
What do you think Ryan Bader won the ultimate fighter way back in the day,
forever ago.
So long ago.
Those wrestling,
they paid her six too.
I didn't know.
He's that tall.
It's a big boy.
He's fairly narrow.
Like he's not like,
let's see phase different.
Well how olds,
I'll toss to the t phase e five 10,
10.
We're plug.
Where's he from?
What's his equity phase?
Albanian.
See if that's true.
But he lived,
he wrote Swedish,
right?
He grew up in Sweden.
We have county,
I'm going to say Afghany say,
I'm pretty sure it rose from the comic store said that's her Albanian brother.
God Damn,
he's Jack find out.
And these,
uh,
these guys from Albania,
she's right.
This guy's a tank though,
man.
Like you get to the size of them.
If you look at his fucking head like he's a tank.
If I'm Beta I wear his ass out and looked for to knock them out in the late
second or third.
Yeah,
he's super explosive.
It says he was born in Sweden.
Says all Sweden.
Yeah,
but he's not to say anything.
Albania.
He must be,
I can go to the Wikipedia,
but it's born and raised in Sweden.
Um,
cause they don't make them looking like that in Sweden was the same ethnicity.
This is Albania.
Albania.
There you go.
Look the same.
Yeah,
they do it their way and these Goddamn yt blue.
I'll tell you what though.
Musashi eight the fucking shit out of a Latifi.
His whole world just took the TV,
took that fight on super short notice because somebody else got injured.
There was a last minute fight.
I was t phase first fight in the UFC teeth.
He doesn't have a good Latifi going to happen.
Like he,
he doesn't have a big wind.
This would be his biggest one by far in the UFC wasn't really beat anyone that
good.
So this would be his biggest opponent for sure.
But he's a spooky dude.
Oh I hate this fight for Beta.
Especially coming off a loss for Anthony Johnson.
S in fucking Germany.
Well let's see.
Phase a world class wrestler too.
Yes.
The other scary thing about,
so Bader is most likely going to be out wrestled by him.
Like if they just go wrestling the wrestling and [inaudible] starts you with one
shot.
Like he clipped him right there.
He just clipped him with a left talk.
Remember Beta has power too though.
Mariette go over on the ropes.
Eight a fucking hook from Mars.
Well,
he won the ultimate fighter by bombing on Vinny Magalhaes.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
I beat the Braves of the wrestling college him and came around the same team,
but he's,
you know,
he's fighting a guy with a lot gain and subsidiaries power and a guy that
doesn't have a lot of miles on them.
That was a good right hand there by Beta.
Latifi has a lot of miles on because the world wrestling shows which in a
stance,
it's kind of what I'm saying Joe Wrestling Training you mean?
Yeah,
all of that wrestling.
I mean granted Bader grew up restaurant too,
but a little different on the world level.
Let the chief has really reaching,
he's trying to close the distance like with these frantic sprints and baiters
like really elegantly sliding out of the way,
not their number look good data.
Ooh,
Nice Kick Raiders beat Phil Davis.
Rashad Evans like Osp.
You'd meet some fucking guys.
Man.
He's been in there with way better competition on the hunter.
Of course.
100% no question.
And here's the thing about the CFA,
like he's gotten this big power,
but if you look at like his tactical approach,
like how he's trying to approach,
um,
Ryan,
he's trying to step and then bomb and if it works,
look,
if he catches you with one of those things,
Foxville but a guy at Ryan's level,
we shouldn't really be getting caught with that stuff.
And so he switched up the wrestling and Ryan's stuff to take down.
So now Alere is like definitely losing this round so far and he's losing it in
terms of like strategy though,
his ability to execute.
So he switches to South Pole.
Oh,
kick to the body by Beta (306) 302-3013 minutes into the first round.
So if you want to sync it up with us,
yeah.
Latifa does not look good right here.
And he's excuse getting clipped with a kick and look how easy bait or a block
that punch,
because it's obvious,
you know,
it's that looping,
that looping,
right,
that comes Latif even got double unders can take better down.
I mean,
people under estimate baiters wrestling,
they forget about it cause he really doesn't use it that much.
It's interesting how like the certain things that you just absolutely predict,
right?
Like if a guy catches your leg,
if you throw a right kick and the guy catches your leg,
he's gonna throw a right hand.
Like every time you know that,
right?
Hands comment.
You know,
it's unusual approaches to those real common situations.
Oh,
it keeps water check.
Oh the TFA throwing bombs.
Her a fucking fader clocked him with that South Honda.
Yeah.
Latifa is trying to sprint out them in these uh,
in these headaches.
She engineer's gonna catch a knee man.
TV's hair said.
See Ya.
Why not just shave it?
Right.
Fellas got most of it shaved.
I think he just lets it grow with his beard for a couple of days.
Elite.
That's a cool name in there.
So Beta is doing a lot of switching stances.
Looks Great.
It looks real loose.
A big loss like the Johnson one man.
Especially when you come out that huge win streak.
I'm sure he went back to the drawing board just to improve on stuff.
But if he get past and then give them like a Gusman next,
he's right back up in there,
man.
Especially at two oh five like who knows what's gonna happen with John Deasy
rumble,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean everybody just assumes that a rumble catches you go to sleep no matter
who you are.
Well that's,
that'd be correct.
Unless John,
you see he did catch DC and put it up on his ass Beta like good,
good technique there.
Holds the left hand high pinned to his face,
throws that counter right hand and he's able to throw like check hooks on both
sides.
Oh,
got a lyric trust,
takedown.
Baiters fucking on one tonight.
Double unders can do shit.
Oh yeah.
It looks good man.
It looks good.
And also you got to realize that the TFA,
we're four minutes into this fight.
He's been unsuccessful for four minutes.
Mine's got to be fucking with them.
Not even close either to fuck with you.
Oh,
we just,
it just connected with a left hand.
He just connected with a left hand.
That's,
that's the danger in fighting this guy.
Yeah.
He'll ball much power.
Look at him.
It's the way it's coming from the fucking,
he's got to figure out a way.
Well you know,
you don't learn it.
You fight a guy like this.
You got to figure out a way to do it technically and then bomb selectively.
Correct.
These guys that try to bomb exclusively,
those guys go dry.
They run out of gas.
Especially when you're getting in the top five.
Yeah.
I mean 1212 to 15 you're,
you know,
you're fine.
But like Lafarge even Hector lumbar does that,
you know,
and he's an experienced guy with a,
a world bell tour championship.
That's why he caught him.
That's what we were talking.
Knows what he should break free man and keep bombing.
Ryan Bader is in
Beta,
got shipped.
Son Dan is tough dude.
And let me tell you something.
Okay,
fuck you got around the fight.
How do you score the fight?
How do you square that round?
This is a good question.
He'd,
he'd knocked him.
You got to get it.
Yeah.
You got to give us the later was winning,
30 seconds of that still and he knock him down and he got the Nazi.
There's no way you want to give it to the other to bait her.
There's no way you're going to give it to Bader is the end of the,
again,
I'd give it a draw.
Good.
I say under the round and he got knocked down and you're going to give it to
Beta.
Okay,
but a ton but a down and the scoring was an MMA is not the same as knocked
knockout in boxing.
If it was boxing,
that would be either a ten eight round or a nine nine rounds.
It's done boxing though.
It was all striking grappling,
but boxing scoring.
So Eddie scoring,
when a guy gets knocked down and there's a point,
Eddie,
I'm not saying that.
Not to say that.
Eddie,
Brian.
So let's say he knocked him down the first 20 seconds of that fight and then
Bader one,
the rest,
four minutes and 40 seconds.
Who would you give the round two that's different.
It's not the same.
It is for Sam.
You described a totally different situation around Andy got knocked down.
Round means more at the end of the [inaudible] it's the guy would personally
count.
I said,
Doug,
how are you doing toward the end of the [inaudible] guys,
Robert of the police.
That's not the way the judging works.
Fellas.
Come hate to tell you it's true.
It's true.
Like as far as like what the fight is or how it's being judged because of the
rules that we're talking about.
Two totally different things.
If you're looking at the fight.
Yeah.
If this was a fight in the street and Latifi got pulled off of him at the last
second,
everybody would think with Tfa one.
Well that's like the navy is funding the sport and he won.
Well,
he knocked him down at the very least.
At the very least he made it a debate.
Could have been over right there with some more time.
Yeah,
but he survived.
It doesn't,
you got Bader on that road.
Uh,
I think to have a drawl.
Yeah.
It could be.
Never heard.
I didn't see Bader doing anything besides stuffing takedowns though.
He didn't really connect a lot.
He's got his front head lock here to gun control.
Good.
Because that means that means baders probably kind of tired when he got clipped
there.
Yeah.
Bidders.
That's true.
He was pressing it though.
You guys just got to know how they score the round.
Yeah.
I want to know how you scored it.
Not how other people's score.
I would give that a draw and even round.
Okay.
Just because one guy does something with last 20 seconds.
That's like saying the Connor Diaz fight man.
If that was a fight fight,
Diaz would probably just about my sport.
I'm not talking about Allie.
Right.
But see Faye threw a punch.
I always like flinch when dudes threw a punch and they land with the thumb dog,
you know,
and they throw that light right hook but it doesn't land knuckles.
That's why I have this fucking earthworms scoring my arm.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
And on that it fucking compound fracture.
The TFA just did that.
He just threw a whipping bomb of a right hand.
He landed with his thumb and I'm like Ooh.
And it usually lands on like skull,
like not on.
It's the worst.
Shatters your bone to keep an eye on his right hand.
I shall.
I shattered my right thumb and when I got a surgery as the doctor went,
how's the scarlet?
I did my best.
It looks like a fucking,
it's like a Senate peed on my right hand.
So you're saying it comes from my throwing that over that long hook?
Yeah,
like a straight arm hooked and you hit with the thought.
Oh Shit.
Going down like that.
That's what I said.
He kept that,
that makes it easy.
That makes it even a step in his hand and he's to get caught or Bader dot away
with fucking grammys.
Ryan Bader,
dangerous flight.
She's just such a dangerous fight and hurt at the end of the first round and
comes back with that shot.
Holy Fuck Man.
Yeah.
Now was that a kicker and neat.
It was a knee.
He kept going down like that.
He cause he's a salad.
Let's see.
Circle.
I think it was.
He's doing bull boats.
He was going for it.
Awful.
Oh my God.
Look at that.
Go Away.
Yeah.
That was a kick landed on the knee.
Dangerous.
That looks God.
It was perfect.
Perfect timing though.
Udl Shit.
God Damn [inaudible] in the first round.
This.
Ooh.
That kind of looks like a neat,
it's like he adjusted the it definitely Glasgow for a kiss and then just fall
through on the knee.
I think he might have adjusted and turned it into a needle,
but being arrested,
the instinct look like he'd just would keep going for that double when he got in
trouble.
God Damn Ryan Bader.
Holy Shit.
That's huge.
Such a big win for him.
That coming off that loss to knocked out win top four.
You're getting gusts for next son.
Enjoy that.
It's a tough fight.
Joe Silva is Joe Silva definitely out now.
He's retired.
He said,
I made bank son.
Is he done like this year or is it done right now and to the year.
Wow.
And I made my money.
Fuck this silly matchup stuff.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Sean.
Shelby take care of this.
He must.
It's interesting.
That's what they say Pam
paid and what's he do after this?
Just lead the charge on morning Joe.
We'll just start doing UFC patrol charge.
He's the head troll online now.
Cut to Joe Silva's next project.
Quick Youtube.
Clip him in a diaper.
Picked cage.
Bam.
Coming soon.
It's called.
He may be short,
but he's got a dick and just all luck.
Big dudes in MMA gloves.
Boom.
It's like he was going for a kick and then adjusted in mid swing and turn it
into a perfect name.
You could see it.
Yeah.
See?
See how he turned the hip,
the knee and toffee.
Beautiful.
Talk that the fuck man.
That's amazing.
Good for Ryan Bader.
Congratulations.
That's huge.
It's amazing.
Again that he's only 33 I mean we've seen this dude in the UFC for a long time,
but realistically like he's in his prime right now.
Right now.
Yeah.
32 to like 35 starts to especially light heavyweight or heavyweight around 35 36
you start going,
hmm.
If you're not doing anything,
how long can you keep this up?
Yeah,
yeah.
If you're not,
yeah,
you're not on an upward trajectory.
It's not going,
hey,
let me ask you that.
Because you,
uh,
you just had Scott Coker on,
well,
I'm a big fan of,
and he went over it.
Yeah.
Great Guy.
And he's a running belt,
are now,
wish him all the luck in the world.
Powerful Matt Hughes.
That's a chant.
That's an American channel right there off the fucking America hair cut.
That's an American period,
Joe Zone.
Abu Dhabi aspect about that.
Yeah,
they're gonna have a grappling match.
That's awesome.
Um,
but uh,
Scott Coker running a belt or if you're a fighter and a,
you know,
quetsion you know,
you lack a little help,
you know,
and train.
Sometimes we tired and uh,
you know,
just a little pick me up,
run away from the doctor and you know,
no one need to know a couple of days I'll be back.
My friend,
my friend,
you know,
there had been doing that since the beginning of time.
They've been taken a little something,
something and then they get to the way in and all they have to do is pass what
most fighters call the intelligence tests.
Don't get popped after the fight,
you know,
so it'll,
it'll help you with your training and how many guys are like looking at belter
and saying,
well this is,
no,
you sat over there.
He can fight a longer,
oh,
not only longer.
My hobbies,
how about better,
better,
better.
And I can have all my sponsors.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh,
well we can't find Brendan.
He's on a mountain somewhere in Colorado and we can't get on his test off of him
and why he just sat there.
Just veins coming out of your jacket and your face and your,
your tongue as veins and rocky mountain oysters just doing dead lifts.
Fucking 34 35
yeah,
man.
I mean there's a,
there's a real enough to go there for real incentive.
And then there's a financial incentive because you can keep all your sponsors.
You don't have to worry about having
a Reebok pair of shorts on.
You could have Nike and fucking underarmour and condom depot and whatever the
fuck that's what's going on with GSP and UFC,
right?
Like just be goes.
So I retired,
but his contract freezes.
So the contract doesn't change because the last thing you thought was 2013 he
still has that old contract.
So he comes back,
they just go,
yeah,
turn the contract back on.
He's like,
Whoa,
whoa.
When I was fighting for this money from the UFC,
I had under Armour,
I had all these,
you know the,
all these crazy brands,
I'm making tens of millions of dollars.
So you got to make up for that and they're gone.
Now we're good.
And he's like,
no,
you can't do that.
I'm fucking George Saint Pierre.
Did you see the,
the,
the war of words he's been having with Dana or Dana is like,
he really doesn't want to fight.
He didn't want to fight a championship level and danger points.
He does not know me.
Yeah.
Gimme one side know me,
he goes,
give me one final show.
He wants to find out how much money do you fucking need UFC just pay the man.
Here's the thing from my perspective,
you can never say that a guy like George doesn't want it anymore unless he
fights.
You cannot say that he is the greatest welterweight of all.
Just two guys.
There's Matthews and there's George Saint Pierre.
Those are the two without a doubt.
Greatest welterweights historically ever.
So if either one of those guys wants to fight again,
the last thing you can,
you can say is he doesn't want it because only he knows if he wants it.
The baddest motherfucker.
You're weighed in at 170 pounds ever and fought.
Everybody might go to Bella tart.
No he can't.
But he owns his contract.
But if that,
but if I was Dana,
I'd probably say the same shit like 100% all there just to get him back.
I'm a shy,
tried it.
I'll do it for free.
Fucking dude I bought kick it back.
I'll get money.
We'll go Jean Georges to smudge.
You hear me?
Cause I know what Dana is trying to do cause I'm too swipe to play these games.
I'll sit out like it's not going to happen is he's sitting out for more moneys.
Have what the deal is.
Why don't you take over Joe Silva's job watch called Dana and say yo bygones.
Let's let the shit go by water under the bridge.
Holla at me dude.
I got flavor and a number one podcast.
Come with me Simon.
Let's take a ride.
Let's do this.
Take a ride.
Come on man.
Some fun.
Have a dude that you argue with all the time and you guys publicly have little
spats.
Everybody gets excited.
Come on,
come on.
It's all good man.
Shake.
I can't wear Reebok so no reason.
One stickler,
he wouldn't.
Where would you wear Yeezys?
You fucking dunce.
You're fucking right and you're fucking right.
I would better.
I thought I had them on right now.
That's a large one.
Serbian,
maybe whatever.
These are like some slick look and chucks,
but these are old school chuck Taylor,
converse man,
a soul.
You feel the grounds are classic fashion,
uncomfortable.
What's,
how dare you.
A long day.
There's not much comfort.
Although they redid the souls on this.
I don't like the new ones.
The souls now I like the new ones as much.
I like them.
They're okay.
I should say I don't like this.
I prefer these.
Those are second,
but for the whole school fucking word bottoms.
You're just ones that,
oh,
those are new sun footwear,
but these are not new.
These are the old school converse,
Instagram,
BM foot where it,
check them out.
Be m footwear,
Vm,
VM.
Don't go BM.
This body bowel movement.
This dude,
these are upgraded son.
I don't have to believe so.
But you feel the salt.
Feel it.
Feel the in the inside of the shoe.
Sole Brennan.
She's lunar line on there.
Where's the green?
No,
no,
no.
They're not the Nike Lunar.
They're just,
the padding on the bottom is thicker.
What they used to be.
Okay.
The inside,
not the Nike Lunar.
There's still a fucking hardest but souls the same.
But the insoles quite a little bit thicker either way.
That's what I like.
I like old school.
Chuck's cause they're flat.
That's like carry your foot's supposed to be like when you wear things where
like an elevated,
he'll like a running shoe.
It's not always supposed to be very good for you.
Yeah.
Your body doesn't want to be elevated in your heel like that.
You're supposed to wear some boots like Eddie when you lifted,
you would always lift with these on,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
They're,
they're,
they're real thin and just that's a fucking shoe there.
Joe,
can we get you to where some Yeezys know why it's a [inaudible] in those things
like why does it have a thin sole and where the toes are?
Shut your fucking mouth facile down there.
Why for pure comfort when he's running in those,
yeah,
it is around how dare you do not work out in these people do that.
I just don't think that they're that cool looking.
I don't like what you're 50 I don't think you're the Democrat and the fact that
I still just down aesthetically they kind of suck.
You and Jamie are on the wrong side of history with these stupid shoes.
I've cons to balance to look back and look.
She was like,
what people do and they're gonna get gonna be like,
I can't believe my wireless back.
You know what?
I will never look back on me wearing sandals with jeans like you do all the
time.
You just can't.
Jesus did it.
Kiss my ass.
I guess Jesus is wrong too.
I always forget about Gustafson and when I think about this and find a while
such a bad ass.
Well,
and also Gustafson is one of those guys that's been talking about retirement.
He's talked about ending it soon he went down to San Diego because he wanted to
find the passion again and I guess he still didn't find it,
so that's why they kind of short kind of a tossup fight.
Yeah,
he's still,
he was saying he's still having some struggles with it.
Well,
he's been public about that.
Oh yeah.
While training for this fight.
That might be a trap.
What?
I'm black,
he's a joke.
Well,
it's not a joke.
He's just inexperienced in comparison to Gustafson,
but he's not,
he's a dangerous guy.
He's from Poland.
They don't fuck around dude.
Gus is the fucking,
you know what I'm saying?
He's,
he's,
he's not a crop one percenter and he almost beat fucking DC,
almost beat John and then he got that fuck freak knockout out by Johnson.
He's lost to just the 1% of 1% true.
True,
true,
true.
It's tough man.
Yeah.
Block of Itch is certainly a,
this is like without a doubt,
like the toughest fight he's ever had.
What are you looking for?
The guy from the James Bond movie had gotten this right.
Look at that guy.
Jesus.
He looks tough.
Definitely kill people.
Yeah.
He's like the guy that James Bond has to fight.
He's like an elevator and it kills them with a pen.
He looks rough.
Like the suit.
He's wearing a suit and it's just,
it's impossible to be elegant with that.
He just looks brutal.
It's not well tailored suit either is,
it doesn't look,
it's not at home in his suit and he's in home and Cammo Kim with a knife or
online classes,
you leave as easy as in home.
That guy doesn't wear the easiest.
You can't get ahold [inaudible].
They're just,
they're so exclusive.
That's tough to get.
What about fake Yeezys from China?
Is that super popular?
It's super popular but it's very easy to tell.
Brian [inaudible] and Brian were at lunch the other day.
Four guys had him on and went Brian and you want to see fake Yeezys Abby's fuck
he's got an iron man.
He's got an Nigga life for that.
How could you tell?
There's little things like on the converse,
you know like maybe the stars black on the converse on the Yeezys,
the stitching on the backs different.
The space between the soles is different.
He's like a sneaker con of sewer assemblies.
Like smelling him like long conversations and know,
you know,
can glue is from Indonesia,
not,
you know,
it goes down.
It'd be the same as someone bought a z 28 and then put ss badges on it.
Well those rems are different.
The exhaust is different.
Right.
Tears different.
Let me see the engine.
Like God dammit,
you're honey Dick Minnis and as he fucking ss cars are just like shoes.
Exactly.
Detailed stalling the details kids.
All on the deets.
Do.
How about your boy Damien Maia?
Dude,
dude,
his Jujitsu is so next level for him to do that to condit just slice through him
like butter.
Ooh,
do can you imagine?
Let's say Wonderboy beats Woodley and they have Damien Maia verse Wonderboy and
it'd be like hot tub time machine,
nighttime three.
Cause you got one guy who just does Jujitsu,
won't guy that just a stand up 2016 he doesn't just do Jujitsu.
The reason why he's able to pull off as as beautiful as you get to this cause
it's wrestling and he can take everybody down at one 70 it doesn't,
not sure,
but it's still one aspect of MMA compared to one aspect of MMA in 2016 right.
But at the highest of highest level,
it's fucking dope.
Dope.
It's dope.
It's like hot tub time machine.
But we just,
you know what I'm saying?
He went back but their skills are ridiculous equivalent cause one guys is elite
world class striker and you saw the guards just elite worldclass grappler who've
like they could compete outside of the UFC.
Right.
In striking or in grappling with Wonderboy,
like took on a kickboxing bound and glory.
He'd be very competitive with some of the best kick hard percent world and if
Damien Maia entered into a major Jujitsu competition tomorrow,
he'd be very competitive against some of the best grapplers in the world.
It's really crazy.
It's cool.
Right.
And it's cool
to have that almost never got Amac.
Yeah.
I can't think of last time.
Something like generally the most UFC fighters,
most of them they couldn't go into like Abu Dhabi or even Ebi and they would get
smashed and let's do a high high level wrestler.
Yeah,
it'd be tough.
Yeah.
And even high level wrestler,
like in a submission only tournament,
Dobby Ebi,
different Abu Dhabi.
There's some high level wrestlers.
The guys that jumped in there with not a ton of just too expensive.
Exactly.
And I would dobby because of the point cause gum rustling becomes fucking
correct.
That's why you can see some guys go all the Brazilians when they're getting
ready for Abu Dhabi,
they're going on a rustling caps it with the church boys take downs.
We,
she just explained it probably is the Abu Dhabi combat club.
This is like the biggest,
so the Olympics.
Yeah.
Shake talk noon.
A guy who owns,
I think he owns 10% of the UFC.
He also,
uh,
is a black belt in Brazilian jujitsu under Henzel Gracie and he puts on these
grappling competitions that are just monstrous.
They spend money and they have the best fighters in the world and they put
together,
they should really adopt Ebi rules.
Do like blood sport for Jujitsu.
Ebi Rules need to be Standard Algebra and get fucked up tournaments or sweating.
I see it.
And many,
many tournaments are switching to ebi roles that make sense,
son and went to it.
Chill Sundance tournament went to her.
It's smart.
It's the most exciting set of rules by far.
Far not even close.
Now let's go on to the show next week now.
Jihad or you gone?
Yeah.
Geez.
Where's it at next Sunday at the Orpheum La la downtown at the Orpheum.
I'll be EBI official DOTCOM.
We're in.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
What about your next Sunday?
It's going to be fucking amazing.
Gordon and Gordon.
Ryan in New York,
Gotham Comedy Club on Sunday,
September 16th and 17th when is 11 September 11th I'll be around tower seven
day.
Did you guys see Gordon Ryan versus Keenan?
Cornelius?
Go for what?
90 minutes?
No,
monster came into monster,
but Gordon,
Ryan Beta man.
Yup.
20 years old.
Kids been training Jujitsu four and a half years.
Jesus.
But Kenny Cornelius is going to do Ebi November six we're doing the light
heavyweights and Gordon Ryan's going to do that one as well.
Love came.
The next Sunday is one 85 next Sunday is one 85 it's the middleweights Ebi
downtown La at the Orpheum.
What time does it start at?
Five o'clock.
Okay,
cool.
Not,
oh,
it's going to be on UFC fight pass,
but for those of you that don't live in southern California,
so UFC fight pass,
stepping up.
I love it man.
It's so cool that they did that.
Okay,
here we go.
We've got Gustafson versus block.
Covich Gustafson got checked.
I would be willing to bet if Gustavus for whatever reason loses fight is done
fighting.
Damn.
A block.
A bit to the right hand over the top Gus when soap,
which is the way you supposed to say it.
[inaudible]
I'm saying block Covich I think it's public block a bitch.
She called him the block.
The talking about the block
that blow the blow hole.
No,
that doesn't work.
Yeah,
I like the block,
the block.
Oh,
shuck.
He's um,
I don't like to wake essence looking Blah hove which keeps his head,
um,
like right in the center when he's throwing bombs against like a really elite
guy.
He likes stiffens up a little bit.
When he's standing up.
He could get clipped counters,
guests and that.
I trained together for my metro and fight and he went six rounds with a
worldclass boxer and it was fucking a war and then jumped in there,
went three rounds with me back to back.
Wow.
He's a fucking animal animal.
Tough guy.
And you know what I mean?
Like I'm full cm punk for Micky gall sponsor on the back then.
Where's that?
Oh right there on the wall.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
he's famous guy.
Look,
the cm punk thing,
the what?
The thing that's most interesting about it is that he took all his time.
Whoa.
The,
which is throwing some bombs.
He's Steph,
Steph with the neck stiff in there.
He's like,
reach is so good.
It will not as farms.
I'm not in this fight,
but usually it's fucking on point.
His Jabs worldclass Oh,
blow hole.
Which is fighting really well.
Really,
really well.
It's very stiff.
It's using up a lot of energy.
I'll tell you what a surprise you as Guthman wrestling man is,
is his counter wrestling is amazing.
But when he took John Down in the first round,
everybody was like,
Oh shit.
Called that because I was wrestling with,
uh,
with his ass.
Take John.
Dot.
Did.
And I called it.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
Because his wrestling,
so unexpecting and good.
Wow.
That's impressive.
He's so big for two or five or two men.
He's tall a shit.
It's five man.
Yeah.
I always wonder like,
what does a guy like that walk around at?
He's like too high to twenties to thirties so the guy like him,
do you think there'd be any benefit in like a rigorous strength and conditioning
program and moving up to heavyweight?
Yeah,
I mean him verse steep,
it'd be a hell of a fight.
But I think when you got fight guys like Rothwell like steep bay,
jds cane,
I think you might be all right.
I don't know if he doesn't possess the power.
That's the problem.
I Dunno man.
He was knocked guys out.
He knocked Chimi Mattawa out.
I just want him to a high level guy that he's knocked out though.
Well man was pretty high level.
Take it easy.
Let's just be real.
I'm talking about when you're talking about Jon Jones DC,
he's talking about 1% but you know,
the only guy out of that group that,
uh,
that stopped him was rumble and rumble can stop anybody.
And if you look at the way rumble stopped him,
it's actually arguably like more impressive than he lasted as long as it did.
I agree.
When Robin was bombing on,
But those extra shots that he took,
those don't help you.
Not at all.
What's like,
Gosh,
he's making a dog fight.
What's like Carlos Condit,
right.
Like he lose that fight and he's like,
I don't know if I want to do it similar.
Then I heard his coach on the interview,
Brandon Gibson,
powerful branding.
Gibson,
there's his soon to take down Gibson timeout.
I don't know if he wants to do anymore.
He is that he wants to move
on to other stuff.
It's time to get out man.
Yeah.
Can you can still be 98% of the division but still man,
get the fuck out.
Condit he's also a smart guy.
Very smart.
And when you're that smart,
you're aware like,
okay,
how many more shots I'm not going to be able to take?
Well he was at like,
what was he,
1617 doing valley Tuto bare knuckle boxing and shit.
Like he's a nightmare that age.
Yeah.
He fought his first ever kickboxing match against Andy Sour who's a world
champion.
He's,
and yeah,
if you don't even handy sours fucking out Google Youtube and kind of just my
marvel had conduct how good he's always been.
Any sour is like a phenom,
like a world champion,
multiple time world champion.
That was Carlos is first kickboxing about him.
It's so insane that he took that fight.
He's done bare knuckle stuff.
He's,
you know,
he's just been fighting for Everman so that you know the head trauma and he's
like you said,
he's a smart guy.
He talks about it.
He's open about it.
Once he taught what he said about head trauma stuff or,
yeah,
just like it's a concern of his and he doesn't know if he wants to keep doing
and stuff like that.
He has a second or third baby on the way I think.
So He's a guy.
He's probably got some money in the bank,
I hope.
Yeah,
I don't know.
You know,
I don't know how much money's made.
It's tough with the Gallagher,
he was interim champ,
right?
Yeah.
And then he's always fought like top five level.
But to really make that crazy retirement money,
you gotta be guy like GSP Connor.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Or you got to figure out some way to market yourself outside of the UFC.
I mean,
it's gotta be something like Allen,
Joe Bands doing modeling.
You know,
you broke off in podcasting.
There's gotta be like another way as well,
just,
but to only rely on your success in athletic contests to make your money.
You almost have to Joe,
because Damien mocking up,
thinking about making money anywhere else.
Conduit right now can open up an MMA gym and make plenty of money.
That's tough,
man.
I think that's easier said than done.
No,
it's not that.
Well,
you're a UFC fight your kindness.
I,
I'm the UFC.
The UFC gyms would beg to differ very doomsday for demos.
They say that they're not doing well.
I'm just saying in general,
if you go off to a general consensus of opening a gym,
if you do get your money back with a return within four years,
it's not a smart business going black belt and you're a legit,
if you're a UFC fighter and you're a black belt,
doesn't mean you're not.
I'm in the,
this is my business.
You're a great teacher.
I talk.
No,
he doesn't even have to teach.
He doesn't trust me.
He could make plenty of money with his own gym.
Have two gyms,
super easy.
You just got to be a black belt at the marketing,
learn the market and learn how to do it.
He's got a black belt and he's a UFC fighter.
I know guys that are,
that are purple belts that are making a living.
Sure.
They just have the marketing down.
It's huge.
It's still growing.
It's expanding Jujitsu schools and MMA gyms done.
Right.
It really is like a,
like the gold rush.
I agree 100% of just putting up it's wide open.
We now,
let's now you're assuming he has the money put down to open a gym.
She could do it.
Easy,
easy.
Oh Dang.
1000000% easy conduct.
Famous UFC,
smart black.
I'm not saying he can't.
I think to assume I can open a gym and make a Shitload of money.
It's 1000000%.
1 million percent.
So anyone the UFC could do it.
And if you're a black belt,
if you're,
if you're a legit black belt and you,
you've had success in the UFC,
uh,
remember,
I mean like I just said,
I've had guys that haven't been in the UFC,
not even black belts and there being there,
you just gotta you just gotta another business.
There's a,
there's some things up big if though is,
am I wrong?
You're just like that no one running a business and knowing how to fight as a
completely different world.
Yes.
That's why I said if you master the marketing and that doesn't,
that's a big gift to learn how to speak Spanish.
She could write awesome books.
No,
but it's not that Spanish learning Spanish.
It's easier than I believe it begged the two cause it's like your money and it's
your family.
It's not that hard.
And Arnie had dealing with this every day.
I deal with this every day and you're brilliant at it.
Doesn't mean it's easy.
There's a lot of guys,
but it's easy.
It's easy.
All you gotta do is know the system and work hard.
That's it.
You work hard if you're lazy and I ain't going to happen.
But that's the true with everything.
There's so many people that are looking for it.
There's a lot of things that,
no,
but there's a lot of things that require to shit that you can never learn.
Like being a standup comedian.
If you don't,
not everybody can do that,
right?
Not Everybody.
Not everybody can be a singer.
Not everybody,
but everybody can do certain things in business.
All you gotta do is do the work and not be lazy and you can make it happen.
Blow Hole.
You don't need a special talent
bill Holt,
which cannot get off his back.
Powerful wrestling.
But yeah,
he's getting smushed.
But I didn't know a lot of elbows.
I agree with you,
Brandon.
1000000% on once a fighter starts doubting,
you know,
whether they,
they have the heart.
I think it's time.
Yeah,
it's time to just say shy like Carlos trends.
It's time to transition.
It's also an absolute fact that when you get hit in the head a lot,
it starts to affect your enthusiasm.
It starts to affect your endocrine system.
It's,
there's a potential,
like I know a guy was a worldclass boxer and I know a friend who trains him who
said that he absolutely has pituitary gland damage and he has a really hard time
getting the energy up to train and he had his testosterone checked and it's just
ridiculously low and there's nothing they can do about it cause it's
supplemented.
It is illegal so they can't supplement his testosterone.
So this guy is forced to fight with low testosterone,
low enthusiasm.
He just can't muster up the kind of performances he had earlier in his career.
And that's super common man.
When you see fighters slowed down as they get older,
it is not just because they're older as because they're older and they've taken
a lot of punishment.
Those are the big factors and it causes a physiological change in their body.
Yup.
Well,
you see like some guys like Chins.
Oh,
Machida chins was like not nine years old,
but he doesn't have a lot of fights on him.
And so he's fighting and belt or now he looks like a world beater.
He looks fucking fantastic.
Starching dude.
Damn.
Starching kicks starching good.
He looks like his brother and a lot of ways he looks like Liotta.
Maybe even a little more aggressive than Liotta.
He's aggressive.
He's very aggressive.
Yeah.
How's his Jujitsu and stuff?
Very good.
Great.
Well he's an elite elite martial arts.
Martial arts is such a good guy too.
I bet he's a good [inaudible] is an awesome guy.
Yeah,
they're all great.
But the point being that like that guy hasn't taken a lot of mileage,
so even though he's 39 years old,
he looks fucking good.
He doesn't only like a 39 year old guy who was at the tail end of a long MMA
career and he's got all these injuries he's constantly struggling against and
can't get through camp without getting hurt.
It's not like that.
You're looking at a guy's car tissue.
Yeah.
Well that's like the cm punk argument,
right?
He's 37 or 38 whatever he is,
and he has a lot of injuries come from professional wrestling and he's never
done the sport.
So then he has to train two years and then go into it.
You're talking about a different animal.
It's not a good fucking,
it's not like if you look at it like a,
a plan like this is way I want to get into MMA.
It's not a good plan,
but this is the plan that he was dealt.
I mean he's 37 years old.
He decides he's going to do it now.
He does a lot of things that I'd like.
It goes to brewfest sport,
which is outstanding.
Jim,
one of the blanket with world class trainers and world costs,
sparring partners,
and then on top of that he took two whole years.
So it's as good as the guy could do two whole years,
two whole years.
Pick about,
think about gaming,
gaming,
Maya's damage he's taken throughout his career.
He hasn't really taken any drastic 13th or hunches in his last what,
four or five?
Yeah,
13 incredible.
Flip the fuck.
What fight was involved in that?
That he received the most dam.
Nate Marquardt starched him with one punch.
I'll really know how to kick.
He struggled for a while there.
You know what he did?
He figured there's a guy who broke down all his Jujitsu on,
on youtube into four parts.
It's pretty fucking interesting.
You go through his early decisions on the ground to the decisions he's making it
making now he has got this path,
well he,
the passes that he's using now that he,
he kind of tripods and it's kind of like a smash pass.
He's just,
he gets to top half.
He knows that if he just hovers over,
keeps his head on his opponent's chest and he's pinning him down and he gets the
top happy,
doesn't even need to pass it on.
Then he turned,
he's not taking any damage.
Then he goes to three quarter mount and then from there he throws a couple
punches.
The guy gives him this back because in three quarter mount you'll basically
already have a hook and he's figured out this path nice and simple.
There's so many things you can do.
As did you get to black belt to pass?
Like your first initial move.
There's all these passes,
there's all,
he has chosen the passes to the mount and to the back.
That path is the best path.
He's three,
he's 38 39 he's 39 38 or 39 not sure if he's smart.
If I'm his management and Peel your mail and do the shit,
but he's not fighting anyone to tell you the title shot and you know six in a
row.
You don't fight where you know what's really interesting?
Jake shields beat him and he al grappled them.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We'll get the list.
Judge,
I'll never forget how God damn good Jake shields was and he just submitted the
auto Machida.
By the way,
in Jesus.
He,
Danny beat wordly.
He beat wordly my,
you know he's beat everyone.
You look at the top five guys check.
She didn't he fight Robbie Lawler and beat Robbie.
Robbie Smith.
I'm standing canteen there you got jumped up,
grabbed a hold of his neck and was like,
um,
what's this worldclass squeeze son?
This is a vegan squeeze.
My is doing on his back.
There's a million things you can do.
There's a painting styles.
He's keeping it nice and simple.
All Damien Maia is looking for when he's on his back is the under hood.
Everything is set up to the under hook.
He gets in a Z guard.
He covered,
he times the punch.
As soon as you throw a right punch,
he shoots in.
He has like a z guard.
Then he shoots in,
grabs the under hook and either gets on top and they stand just like chuck
Ladell used to do with the under hook or he uses that to sweep.
I'm like,
he'll get into dog fight and you know what I see?
Simple.
When I see Kim,
I want to see him fight a guy who was a worldclass Jujitsu guy with a wicked
guard,
like a Braulio esteem,
like someone who can,
who's nasty off of his back.
You can see Damion,
yeah,
because he's going to do the exact same path.
Whether the guy knows Jujitsu or not.
The path that he's chosen from the bottom and from the top,
no matter who he's going with.
That's the best path.
When there's no gay,
when there's punches,
when there's elbows,
Damien Maia,
it's just dwindled everything down to keeping it nice and simple on his back.
It's just,
it's funny.
I'm sure he would do it,
but my question is would he be able to execute that kind of a strategy against a
guy like Braulio esteem a bit harder.
That's why I want to see it.
I want to see what a God with a worldclass guard,
but you know for you it does a lot of weird stuff too.
Like he's got that,
that triangle that he does like that underneath triangle that we're like
backwards triangle.
He does he do an MMA?
Yeah,
he's doing him a minute.
Guys done some fine.
When I watch someone like Damien Maia because I don't have that much of a
trained eye,
it doesn't look like he's doing anything different than everybody else.
When he takes your back or when he's got,
he's on top of you and he's controlling you and what and what tips,
things that subtlety of Jujitsu on that level that unless you have a cultivated
I,
it just looks like he's wearing like a sweater or he's clinician,
he's controlling the army's coming in.
He somehow gets that figure for him on his stomach,
but there's no way you're getting that dude off.
You're not getting them off.
And why someone like Carl Carlos,
I can't even get them off.
And Carl's Kinda his experiences at anybody and that's where that,
that level of mastery is so subtle and almost invisible.
It's hard to see unless you really know what the hell he's doing because a lot
of it seems to be like where he's putting his weight,
those little differences,
how he's countering,
how he's predicting what you're going to do before you do it.
Will that path that Maya is on,
the techniques that he's putting together,
the treasure map that he's on,
Carlos condit probably wasn't getting someone,
uh,
on a daily basis at a high level,
hitting him with that specific right path.
Those moves that he chose,
that he's strung together nice and simple,
nice and tight.
And uh,
um,
you know,
you got to prepare for something as simple as that.
You got to prepare for someone coming at you.
Exactly like that because everything that Maya chooses,
all those positions are the best positions for MMA.
No doubt.
And he's,
he,
he's got a pasture it out.
Yeah.
He's figured out the path.
There's a million moves,
but he's got the path and it's the same shit he's doing over and over.
How Damion,
each smaller,
you know,
I want to see guys like,
Rafael Lovato is now getting into MMA and he's had a few MMA fights,
uh,
outside of the U is going to do well.
He's going to smash guys.
It's a very similar style.
That top heavy pressure just grinds.
It's
one position in the next like small,
methodical one position his,
his chest and he was so heavy.
It's all Hixon Gracie lineage,
Hixon Gracie Salahi Barrow and he's with sallow.
It's like that,
that old school solid Jujitsu.
Like that fucking scary.
Perfect based.
You did too.
It's really not as specific.
You can't breathe.
It's,
it's the specific moves that he's choosing.
It's how he's doing it's oxide to pick all of them.
Are you talking about the Maya were talking about how failed Lavato so he does
have that smashing high level you Jitsu,
but there've been a bunch of high levels.
You get to guys trying to transition into the UFC.
The problem is they're not selecting the moves that Damien Maia selecting
everybody in MMA right now.
If you're not studying,
if you're in the UFC and you are not studying exactly the moves the Damien Maia
has chosen and the path,
it's all laid out for you.
That's the path you need to get on.
There's a lot of different tech,
Jujitsu techniques,
a lot of different styles of playing God,
different guard passing styles.
There's all this shit you can decide to do in the mountain.
Three quarter mount,
all these decisions,
gaming,
mice,
making all the right decisions.
If you're not studying in his shit.
I mean there's the catalog into the ticket there.
Yeah.
He went through some shit to figure out himself.
There's an evolution.
He wasn't choosing that exact path.
Early Australia stand too much on the bottom.
He was always about the under hook it from his early days.
But what he changed his,
he doesn't sit when he's on top,
he never sits into a z half guard.
He calls it headquarters.
He doesn't sit into that anymore because when he wants people to do to sit and
dizzy guard,
when he's on bottom cuts from there,
he just waits for you to throw a right punch and he times it,
he shoots for the under hook cause you just left a big ass opening and from
there he gets the dog fight.
That's all waiting for.
So he doesn't want to do that because he knows that that's the actually the
wrong thing to do.
So we try pods when he's in that headquarter position and he gets up and he
drives his head down and then he just,
he maneuvered his way in the top half and then he turns towards it like it's
really simple.
It's not like he's mixing it up.
He knows the best shit.
You know who else is in an MMA recently?
I just found out that Tiffany van hoose the to me time,
she fights in Invicta I think next week or two weeks.
Is it a first MMA fight?
I think so.
It's your first time.
I'm sure we'll chat.
We'll chat.
Moitai nasty,
nasty,
nasty little tiny girl.
She's the one 15 right?
You got to be 14.
Yeah.
But when you look at the winds division,
she's going to be in the UFC quick knock in bitches out to,
well fuck if she can avoid the take down.
It's going to be interesting because she's based,
she's Gianna's.
She's in Gianna's that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Jamie,
bring her up for a sec.
Let me see your Tiffany time.
Isn't it crazy that just maybe four years ago,
uh,
women's being huge in the UFC was,
I mean most people thought that would never happen because
she's beautiful.
She's a world champion Muay Thai and she,
uh,
I think she lives in Bali,
but then she does a camps out here.
She's doing it right,
man.
She's bad ass,
bad ass.
If you've seen her on access TV just knocked in,
bitches out left and right all the time and with little gloves it's going to be
very interesting.
I think she's training at a alliance down there teaching part of it.
She has her same striking coach from white tie but then I think she's doing some
at alliance.
If I was just going to be a level of technique that she has that most girls just
are not going to be able to hang with.
Just such a big advantage.
So Joanna's pretty fucking high level dude.
I agree but let,
let,
let tiff get a few fights.
Then he got yourself a real burn.
Burn it cause everyone else in that division can't even match up with a strike
and wise.
His Tran.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a lot of dangerous kickbox and women that are coming over now like a
Valentina Shevchenko you see when she puts Holly Holm Down,
she's fighting in the UFC.
She do you know what I'm talking about in belt or the chicken belt?
Valentino.
When you see like all her years of of [inaudible] experience at a world
championship level,
when she fight someone like Holly,
you get to see that like,
oh there's levels to this shit.
Plus they there that,
yeah,
that check hook that you kept nailing it with a check.
Right Hawk like Holly got rattled like early in the first round.
He realized like the timing is very different for someone who's that good plus.
Plus those girls that come from that super high level background of striking was
boxing,
Muay Thai,
whatever it is.
You don't really see women come from a high level background other than those
two.
The ones that do,
I have to just to some of Kenzie dern she's in now in the UFC with high low with
WHO's killing it.
Well she's not in it yet,
but I mean then she just women out.
She did.
She had one fight.
Mackenzie dern.
Yeah,
UFC.
Yeah.
I'm just saying Joe from history with women's fighting,
usually they come from that high level striking background.
They have such an advantage because they've been in the live fire.
You know what I'm saying?
So when they get in the UFC,
he knew the fight and the girl who maybe she just likes to fight and do it all.
When they fight these super high level strikers,
they're fucked man.
Yup.
A lot of them.
That's why you know,
that's where they're going to need that wrestling and Jujitsu and I don't think
about Daymond Maya's when he gets the back,
a lot of people get the back and MMA,
but he ha he's on that Marcella Garcia level,
but when he gets your back,
he knows how to close and he knows how to finish.
It takes so long to have that master because anybody could get on a back and put
the leg hooks in and then they got the over on Fiverr,
but people to be able to close that shit.
It's tough.
It takes a while and he got to the point now in the beginning it probably,
he wasn't really known for taking people's backs and choking him like really,
really easily.
It took a while,
but now man,
when,
when he gets your back,
it's very hard to escape unless you're high level,
unless you're already at a black belt.
But you know he gets closes a black belt.
Yeah,
different levels.
How many rear naked choke says Damien Maia got six,
seven.
Dot.
It's like when he gets to that position,
he doesn't even have to get into your chin.
He just squeezes your fucking head,
all that shit.
That's what it's all about.
Closing the deal,
making you tap.
He knows how to make you tap.
Somebody played an interesting video,
a,
they send it to me on Twitter of want to Hickson's black belts in uh,
Australia.
This guy's doing this demonstration with a rear naked choke and he's,
he was saying that the rear naked choke is all about the legs and so he's got
the rear naked choke on and just using his legs.
I was like stretching the body out like,
but applying pressure just with his legs and he was like,
that's what the rear naked choke so about.
I'm like,
man,
I see what you're doing.
And I think that is definitely,
it's definitely,
uh,
it adds pressure.
It adds Po.
But to me,
I think the most important thing is to squeeze all of it because the guy,
every ounce of their body is perfect.
Yeah.
Everything's gotta be perfect.
But your hips,
your shoulders,
your neck,
everything has to be perfect.
That's a high level squeeze,
right?
It's every,
I mean you get like Gary Tonin when didn't he a win Ebi.
He got to run Nigga choke with no hooks in.
Yeah.
If like a guy worldclass squeeze and you get to clean,
uh,
angle on the neck.
If it's clean deep and you're under the chin,
you don't need that like hooks no more.
You know,
and Gary,
Tony and I forget her,
we did that too,
but he did that an Ebi five.
It was fucking awesome.
I forget what we did it to too,
but so he's the guys,
right?
Like legs definitely have a huge factor.
And when someone's got your back and they have like really,
like if you see,
ever see,
um,
when,
uh,
Tokyo,
grappled with mayhem.
Miller,
yes.
Jesus Christ.
And the grappling.
No,
they were in Brazil,
Brazil and he was down there training and uh,
to just,
well I talked to man,
man was like,
hey all y'all,
I was out partying the night before drunk.
It was probably totally true,
you know,
but it didn't matter to Kenya just took it,
took his back like a ghost or took his arm.
I thought that was half size has salivary varies when it was his arm.
You're talking about,
you're talking about when he was smart Pahara pop.
I thought that's what I'm talking about.
Paul Harris.
Yeah,
that's his nickname.
Means tree stump.
But um,
there was a guy like that when they get,
they get your back with those giant ass legs that he has when he's like
squeezing down on your shit and stretching you out as he's choking you.
Fucking Keanio and Polaris.
Yes.
You see that?
Yeah.
Amazing.
That's an example of caring of those submission only matches that ends up in a
draw,
but it was amazing.
You know what I mean?
There's so many bad ass draws out there.
They're not all bad.
Just because it's the draw doesn't mean that,
I mean,
oh,
draw with sideboards to a guy like you or are you who could really appreciate
the technique and sees what's,
did you just say,
look at my drove a Cyborg,
all this sleep debt,
paying attention.
Still don't man.
I know.
It's crazy.
What's crazy about this Ebi coming up?
It's one of the worst case scenarios people would,
would,
would come up to me and ask me about it and I would think about it too,
is like would have someone,
one Ebi by escapes got into overtime and every round and then one by quick
escape time.
Like what would,
would that ruin the show?
And I thought,
damn,
I don't know,
but it wired.
Oh tell us he's a turtle guard master and Turtle Gardens is basically giving up
your back.
So anybody who goes to turtle guard,
very few people can do this.
They got to have the best back defense ever.
If you're going to play turtle guard,
right?
Right.
So he does.
And he's known that and he's known in the Jujitsu communities,
that legend,
Legend,
Legend at defense.
Untoppable this guidewire don't tell us.
So he's doing Ebi eight next Sunday.
You can watch the countdown show on,
on Youtube.
Ebi countdown.
Ebi Eight.
Uh,
he's on the countdown show talking about winning Ebi on escapes.
That's crazy.
So now that's an actual real scenario that we're dealing with.
So instead of killing the show,
now it's like,
it's actually interesting to see if he could win the whole thing by escaping.
So look at this shit.
Ricardo Lamas versus Bj Penn.
October 15th and Manila.
They do that to my boy,
Bj Penn's.
Why not man?
Let's see.
What's a good fight right there.
See what's up.
I keep thinking Bj's retired.
He's,
well BJ honestly should be fighting someone who is outside of the top 20 to like
get his uh,
his timing back,
but let him fight Sam punked.
But that said,
Bj Penn is fucking Bj Penn and Bj Penn wants to fight the tough guys because
whatever he wants,
he can do whatever he wants.
And if
he doesn't fight it,
a guy who's like super dangerous,
he's probably not going to train as hard.
He's not going to get up for it.
So this is how Bj's Kinda gotta do it.
Fucking love smart lamas.
Call him out or something happened around him.
[inaudible] he had a fight with,
was it Bermudez who the fight he had scheduled,
it wasn't tense from you up to meet us?
No,
it wasn't Bermuda.
Someone he had a fight scheduled rents?
No,
it wasn't Nick Lens Cause Nick Lands fighting at one 55.
Um,
they um,
there was some fight that got canceled because yeah,
because Bj had taken a Nivea to rehydrate himself.
That was on the a La Carte.
Yeah.
What was the fight?
I see if your front and out anyway,
so they had to give him another fight.
And so the other fight that gave him as lamas,
which is a tough,
anybody through the fucking one 45.
Bj Penn,
what are you going to do?
But still,
apparently he's,
he's uh,
his fighting stance is back to the old Bj,
right?
Yeah.
He went to Winkle.
John,
you know what I mean?
In Brandon gives you there now and yeah,
he's,
he's been training that.
Jackson's it.
Here it goes.
What does it say?
Cole Miller.
Oh,
Cole Miller is a real good fight.
That's a real good point too.
That's a real good fight.
Did he listen man,
he did.
He went to remember people would say,
what did Bj when to like Jack?
What would happen then?
And he actually did it.
How cool is that?
He speech a fucking pen.
Don't ever forget that.
If that guy's body is willing and he could figure out a way to motivate himself
into awesome shape again,
he is Bj motherfucking.
I think he should.
I think he should just focus on using a striking to take people down and just
take him to the ground.
I think he's still one of the best on the ground.
You know who I don't want to see fight again and I hope,
I hope for whatever reason,
contractual.
It doesn't happen as GSP man,
his last like three or four fights,
so many hits to the head.
He has money in the bank.
The 70 pound divisions completely changed now.
I just don't want to see it.
Maybe he's bored.
He promptly,
he must be bored as fuck.
Making like kickbox or two and shit.
Yeah,
and he did something with a cigar or so.
God kills him and some movie that would make me want to fucking get back to
anything else.
Different video that he's not been missing any meals.
Oh,
he's so big now.
She's so big.
It's crazy.
He would fuck you guys.
Is this giant barrel of a chest he's like,
has got to be a hundred pounds overweight.
Yeah.
It's really weird because like if you go back to like hard to kill like this
first.
Oh my God,
he looks awesome.
I used to like him man under sea.
Each one watch your mouth.
Posy did a bunch of weird stuff that nobody's ever seen before.
A bunch of smacking.
Like it's like if you go and watch Steven Seagal is earliest movie.
It was hard to kill,
right?
No,
no.
It wasn't for justice saw above.
Above the law,
justice and Bob above the laws as first one.
It's fun to watch like his fight scenes.
You're like,
I kind of feeling this.
I feel like he could pull this off.
You know,
he's kind of doing like wing Chong,
but he's smacking some fucking clothes lines on people and sweeping them off
their feet and snapping arms and shit.
I think it's actually kind of a good actor too under siege ones too is fucking
brilliant.
Laura's feels great.
Who does face in [inaudible] 88 and 88 above the law.
Handsome too.
Time piece and hard to,
Kenny was only probably 30 years old back then teaching a Kido in Japan.
He was a first American to run a Dojo in Japan.
That's under a,
that's been a contestant.
Shut the fuck up Brian.
Why are you ruining?
Sorry Buddy.
Sorry,
I'm looking at it back then.
Look at the body,
but that's a body of a guy who actually knows martial arts.
Now he's um,
or not.
I mean,
I don't know sort of that nude John Claude van Damme show cause John Claude van
Johnson,
he plays himself and he's Van Johnson.
The reality show.
Dave Callahan wrote that the D my student who wrote a Godzilla.
Yeah.
Yes.
And show now it's on Amazon or I don't even know,
but I'm Tate's in it too.
Really?
It's got John Claude van Johnson.
It's about John Claude van Damme is in any plays himself and he's like this like
washed up actors.
Like he's just himself.
So it's a story about John Compton dam and he's playing himself but making fun
of like a parody.
Yeah,
it's kind of like that little bit.
Damn Times.
Choose to watch it.
I love it.
Supposed to be plenty of shit.
Can't that shit.
Can't do it.
I remember him from bloodsport.
Okay.
Awful.
Josh Barnett still swinging.
Got Debit.
That's a total bilirubin is still throwing leather.
Tough fight to call man.
Two vets.
Yeah.
You saw the testing Germany.
Well,
I mean,
who would have ever predicted that are Lawsky would've gotten that close to a
title shot again after all those years out,
I have to get in starched barked surgery Keratan off after getting beaten down
by rumble Johnson to come back from all that,
get back into the UFC and work his way to the top for like what amazing.
How the fuck did he do that when to Jackson's got a huge four or five fight win
streak.
Amazing.
I mean,
it's amazing when like a lot of people thought the care I'll fight.
Like they,
like someone's got to step in,
someone's got to knows.
It's amazing the difference in his nose now.
And when he first started fighting,
did you know many times this guy's been knocked out?
Like if you really look went over like his entire career,
I would like to find out,
well,
between him and Overeem,
it's a God damn highlight ran in training.
I wonder.
Yeah.
Overeem's had a lot of style more than anyone.
Well all the kickbox losses.
MMA losses.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
A lot of these guys have been stopped a lot of times.
I'm too slim for this.
When he
knows,
I know that's a guy who's been in some wars,
man who's been in as many slug fest is our Lawsky Dan Barnett.
Barnett has,
yeah.
I mean they're close.
But Andrea is almost always in slug fest cause he's a,
you know,
he's
not like trying to take someone down as Josh Barnett been knocked out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He got knocked Travis Brown elbows to the back of their real,
real,
real bad.
And then,
um,
before that though,
he has for sure and the Grand Roswell just choked him out.
Yup.
Rothwell caught him with that crazy finger Gogo gay teens,
whatever it calls it.
Go,
go get your team to so many different ways to put on that guillotine.
And they're all secretive because you can never see the grip and everyone has a
certain way they hold a grip,
never gets a hidden grip.
There's probably 13 different,
at least killing our Lawsky went old school with the,
with this pregame fight interview too.
He's talking about how when he was the UFC champ,
Barnett was in prides and how our last,
he wasn't the real champ.
He was.
Yeah,
but,
but John [inaudible] was never a champion Raj ago.
I know,
but he was just,
he was a runner up and he's the one they were asking Barnett back then.
He was like,
God,
UFC champ doesn't really count.
I lost,
he's not the real champ.
Or Laski brought that shit back like an old elephant in,
forget.
Wow.
He's like,
excuse me,
sir.
That was 20 years ago.
Oh,
they'll have like an old Belarusian elephants.
It's another one.
If you look at him,
he's 37 that's amazing that he was,
he was like elite in the UFC and it's early,
early twenties and Josh Barnett,
a youngest heavyweight champion.
Ever.
Rarely.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
When he beat Randy couture,
he became the youngest ever UFC heavyweight champion.
But then didn't he get stripped?
It stripped,
stripped the pissed hot.
Yeah.
He's pissed hot shit between him and over him.
It's a god Damn God.
The MLB and the in the,
in the glory days,
Mark McGuire.
Barry bonds too bad asses.
They'll piss hot.
It will be interesting if Bella toward just becomes like a PD ling pride.
Just ped league.
Just let them do whatever.
Taco Bell said that he's like our,
our walkouts.
We tried to mimic pride.
I'm like,
yeah,
for sure.
Just look guys juice to the Gill and do that.
Do you hate money Mr Coatsin try.
I smoke juice to the guilt.
I mean someone's got to explain to me Bobby Lashley explain why.
Explain.
Explain what's going on there.
How's that possible?
Why can I say a picture of place?
You're going to see him [inaudible] he's a very strong,
powerful wrestler.
Dot.
Jack is the cover boy for the smell test.
Look at them.
Well that's um,
that's the craziest Shit I've ever seen him.
That's,
that is so ridiculous.
Now does he moonlight as a bodybuilder or used to be?
Look at.
That's natural.
Those tribes are all natural and he fighting in Beltour looking like that.
Yup.
Yeah.
Show a picture of him in bells.
Dolce way.
Taking a lot of dolce way.
Rustler though.
Look at him there,
Jerry Bellis or look to the size of them in tour.
Yeah.
Now listen,
some people are just born super muscular,
but he only fights it funky places like they're not local Indian casinos and
shit.
That's great.
Crazy shit.
This is the thing,
the nicest guy in the world.
Honestly,
on some Mexican supplements,
motherfucker can wrestle his ass.
Yeah,
he's a monster.
I can eat it.
I'm looking at him.
I wouldn't say he's a an accountant.
I would say he's a restaurant,
but he know he has.
It's not like cm punk.
Greyson is legit wrestling.
I believe that in the military he's champ and he's had a lot of fights.
You know what I mean?
He fought and showtime for awhile or he's only had I think like eight or nine.
He's not that active.
We Fund strike force and lost a Trad Griggs.
Remember grave digger?
Yeah,
that's right.
The grave digger.
And that was like,
that was a big setback for him.
He had to get his shit together again.
Start all over again.
Transplants bodies and interesting.
You know who his training partners?
Josh Barnett,
Bobby Lashon.
Barden train together all the time.
It makes sense.
Never seen by the less you taking now ever.
Okay.
Prediction Orlowski Barnett that looks bigger than us.
Big Man.
They're both giant barn.
It's heavier or lost.
He's in better shape out as soon.
But uh,
Barnett's got a lot of options.
Yeah.
Barnett,
he,
he's like a suicide guy.
His too many options and there's a lot of,
our last few of his only options is to knock them out
over the top.
What's going on?
Hey guys.
Oh,
what tough.
Oh my God.
We all out of our minds here,
one to oldies fucking slanging ice slot.
Just took a big deep breath and by all these 12 years younger than me and Joe
Barnett,
it's sang something.
Brad sang something.
What he's saying he's,
what was he grabbed like gloves.
He's saying he's grabbing my gloves.
Grab my gloves.
Oh,
is that what you're saying?
I think so.
Wow.
Let's shut up and fight.
I think that's what he said.
Did he say that?
I don't think that show.
We said let's just fight.
Wow.
Holy Fuck.
These boys ain't messing around.
Wow.
This is when there are lots.
He does do this.
He's usually out his best.
Like you're thinking about Trump's brown.
We just caution to the wind.
Yeah,
but Barnett is good at controlling the pace here.
When he gets a hold of you like this,
this is going to saps.
Got the string wide hips.
He's just so strong.
So tank of a guy.
It's all,
it's super hard to man.
Fuck.
Oh,
caught on the break.
Who someone's about to get knocked out and get ready to Bulla is,
oh Jesus.
He's bleeding hardcore.
Tough way to make a,
Oh,
don't listen to do that.
Left hook from Barnett coming up.
This is intense.
Someone's going to sleep or real soon.
Oh Damn.
Attack that body.
Oh,
there's like a,
there's like a weird way that our Laski throws his right hand.
If you noticed that,
almost like a,
like a whipping action from the hips.
He doesn't throw it the way he threw it when he was young.
He painted his toenails.
Shut the fuck up.
I don't bring it up.
Sorry.
He's a warlock.
He's a fucking warlock and I knew it.
That's what a bad motherfucker chuck with Delos.
He had everybody paying their damn toenails really did
and no one said Shit.
I'm not saying shit.
I'm just,
I just made an observation.
I'll wind up doing it.
Sacrifice to go to Satan last night and that's why he had a stuff with it take
to
see.
I like her Lawsky point.
Bartonella is backbone.
It's not like parties off his back.
Ramos.
He doesn't party off his back.
He doesn't.
I wonder if she's got some shit off his back and they were holding Aussie man.
Come on.
So he went for a double wrist lock from the bottom for that bully.
Beatdown double risk luck.
Wonder what he was going to do there with that.
Look at a blood coming down.
He doesn't care.
That's a head by blood by looking at,
go ahead.
Give me a charley horse.
This is an interesting fight.
Barnett on his back or lost his legs.
Punch him in the Dick.
He needs to watch his legs here,
man.
If there's one thing Brian,
it does.
No,
it's fucking like luxe done here.
I think you forget the sambo background of Andrea.
I didn't remember when he got,
what's his name?
Tim.
Sylvia in that,
in that,
a lot of strict.
A lot.
I think you forget about that fucking dude.
I think Josh Barnett,
Kiva Guard for one split second.
Barnett is thicker than a snickers right now.
Stop Vanilla snickers doing the damn thing.
Pig Man,
look at that.
Oh,
and they're bolster their bolster skin.
This is the veteran.
Let's wrestle the arts.
Is that what it is?
Okay.
How many rest you rest?
Take it a couple of one,
two old bucks.
Keep the hands up please.
Somebody.
All of you.
Brian.
It looks tired.
Clash heads,
man.
She'd gone Teske as you Ganti man.
Nobody's,
oh boy.
Oh nation by our Lawsky.
Josh tough.
He looks fine.
Josh Barnett looks fine.
Someone's going to sleep.
Barnett switch stances.
Yes.
Was He,
was he standing in the Orthodox earlier?
He was right.
Yeah,
he switches.
Interesting.
I wonder,
uh,
there's our landscape.
Always have black nail Polish.
Sorry.
No,
first time I listened to guide.
Great fight.
Fuck his nail,
Bro.
I'm just saying,
man,
I'm allowed to make an observation.
God,
you're white,
Josh.
Let's get a 10 you're whiter than I am now.
He can't 10 it would look weird on him.
He'd,
he'd looked pink.
He just turns pink.
Right.
He'd be red and get all red.
Come out there like our red fucking pickle.
Yeah.
Fucking giant pickle.
A red,
white and said pick a lobster.
Yeah.
He had a big fucking blonde lobster.
Josh has given up the neck.
He's like,
go ahead and take it.
You know,
I love,
she's begging for those crazy pull good dean
off.
Wow.
Both of them.
I would never think that Josh would lean on anybody like that ever again after
that Travis Brown fight.
Well,
the thing about that is Travis is so good.
I am cause there's leverage.
How Tall Jesus,
oh my goodness.
Slash knockouts on both ends here.
Oof.
Great takedown,
I think tries to only one who can pull off those elbows because he's so tall.
Maybe.
Well he's also just explosive as fuck with them in that position.
It's like that's his spot.
Deer tick and saga and they jumped on that.
You're on the air.
We're doing the the bike companion,
Joe Das.
Well,
Joey,
it's gone too.
You're not watching the UFC on bypass.
Nice
legacy.
To be honest,
dude.
After a minute,
rest a the fights.
You got to watch that overhand right.
Keep telling our Lawsky though.
Keep your head and chin.
That's I,
when I teach clench,
I always say,
use your fucking head.
Spear Spear the chin.
When you what?
When I teach Clint,
when I do,
uh,
clench clinic,
I call it the clinch clinic with the kid.
Nobody ever comes.
But if somebody did,
I would always say,
use your head.
I cannot get anybody to fucking calm.
And I have something to say.
It's on a message board.
It's going to be a quince clinical with the kid piece of paper with a bunch of
things you could rip off that have the phone number on it.
Just,
just one ripped off and he ripped it off from himself.
I put it up on post,
get things,
go on phone calls.
I put it up on foam balls and nobody called,
nobody caught,
can't get anybody in my fucking clinics.
Man.
I have skied.
I have cupcakes and Koolaid for everybody.
How's this not a five rounder,
right?
Brent has the old,
I don't give a fuck.
Isn't every main event five rounds?
Is it a 500 it might be all it is.
It is size it.
The fucking reindeer thing was blocked in those all three.
Did you guys see that thing where those fucking reindeer,
300 of them got a electrocuted d was it 300 of them was,
it's crazy.
How many was what?
Why don't?
Why don't want to say it's funny how many you got to keep your hands up.
323 323 reindeer got electrocuted to death.
They were all standing in water.
Lightening hit the ground.
The ground was soaked with water so they all got barbecue him instantly.
Boy,
these boys are hundreds of core.
Landed a huge,
oh fuck.
It was harp.
So can you just go there and eat them?
Kick,
kick,
go there and eat.
Although it depends on how cold it is,
you know,
if they,
if it was right afterwards,
yeah,
definitely.
So that could happen to us when we were hunting.
Technically.
Technically could happen.
Yeah.
Because of the ground's all wet so it's connective.
So that should shut that shit all the time.
It could happen while we got rubber boots on though.
Yeah.
We have rubber boots on and uh,
also we're not fucking reindeer.
Yep.
God likes me.
Morning likes.
Reindeers that's they're called Caribou.
I call them Karen.
Yup.
They're delicious animals.
If you were there and you,
you came right after the fact,
you'd be psych like,
cause you'd have all the meat,
you wouldn't want it to go to waste.
So it's not even like you,
uh,
you feel bad for shooting the Caribou did,
you're starving the wilderness.
You post those Instagram videos of grill in that fine,
fine,
loud me hungry.
It's my favorite thing to cook.
I cook some last night.
I will say that one you did with the Jalapenos.
Yeah.
That's my shit dog.
My fucking mouth.
I'm telling you.
I know you like you're scared of uh,
Eddie grew up with a fucked up stepfather and so he's got some crazy food issues
cause it's Stepdad used to force him to eat food.
So Eddie's like meat.
Potatoes stop,
don't get,
they'll get crazy.
And you don't eat meat?
No.
She's like super like down in the middle except something I don't like.
It gave me something that brothers now and the milk is not gamey.
That's the thing,
man.
I'm telling you.
It's like,
like if you like a Fogo de Chao,
you like when they come over,
it's not,
it doesn't taste like that because it's,
it's got more firmness to it.
Oh
now,
oh this is not good.
This is terrible.
Barnett is a smasher look at that instant pass full mount grape vine.
Old School car at the Saturday night live ride.
We call it that Saturday night ride.
Got To call it one of the other,
you can't call skydive.
We call it staying alive.
Boy,
if you can last a minute.
He's going to be gas.
Got It for a minute.
Yeah.
I don't know about all that.
You might get as much tier dude,
just hold on time.
He's looking for the arm triangle on that role.
That right Ana.
Did you say?
No Man,
just hold on him.
Yeah,
for sure.
With Josh Barnett,
we'll put a beating on you and that fucking mount position too.
He's an expert at maneuvering.
Get you in bad spots,
you know,
anticipating your defense and dropping those short palm to elbow elbows down on
you.
Those press down.
You Know Jeremy Horn style elbows has a great head arm choke here that he's
does.
Jeremy Horn was like one of the first guys who were always teaching.
I smashing him 40 seconds.
He's got oh nasty looking for that.
RFO He's looking to straighten those arms out.
Yup.
But our last,
he's got fairly good defense,
but not right here.
Come on Andre.
Don't turn it into not 30 seconds.
Oh my God.
He's getting beat on.
Oh Jesus Christ.
It's not enough to stop it though.
Is it?
Because he's getting smashed.
It's over.
He's beating on him,
man now.
Oh,
it was fly.
You got time.
You got to tell you
that time.
You got time.
Oh,
now it's,
Oh shit.
He's going sink Josh Barnett.
There it goes.
Oh,
he's going to survive.
I don't think so.
Yes.
He survived it.
They're not going to stop it.
Oh,
he got it.
Wow.
To what?
A beating.
He took a ferocious bead.
Laughs.
He's in trouble getting up.
He's got to be reeling right now.
I mean his face is smushed and he's tired as fuck.
They has to be,
man.
He just exploded for survival for the last minute.
The last minute was just a crazy swim to shore with sharks biting your asshole.
Is that Winkeljohn right there.
Got to go back out there.
That's,
that's Mike Winkeljohn is a god who was left like right in front of our Lawsky
tools.
That's Mike.
We've
been here a bunch of times.
That's not good.
You've been here 100 times.
Well can literally on the brink of starting you start thinking about
where to either of these guys go from here.
I guess they're both.
They're both in the mix.
Yeah.
Heavyweight division is pretty old take down by our landscape,
but he got to reverse the momentum man mounted way and that's not what you want.
Oh my God.
Barnett just dropping bombs down on him.
Super accurate.
Josh Barnett is no joke,
man.
Come on.
Andrea Barnett also can keep up this pace for five rounds.
He fought Roy Nelson and gave Roy Nelson a beating like that for five rounds.
He did.
That was super impeaches such a vet man.
He's seen it all.
Yup.
Well he's also just so fucking tough.
Durable.
It has so many fucking trick.
But you still got the bomb man.
He's still got the bomb in his hand.
Look at him.
He's trying to set it up.
Oh,
I don't think that Landon dude,
it's weird the way he throws that right hand.
It's like his elbows down,
his shoulders up and he like,
he like whips it.
It's almost like he doesn't throw it straight anymore.
See what I'm saying?
And he throws that kick,
these getting caught.
That's the second time he's gotten caught.
But it's like he's thrown it with his body and then the arm is sort of following
behind it.
It's like whipping.
It's weird.
Oh,
they're so tired.
These guys are,
I mean,
if Kinda,
Oh man,
my Barnett,
right hand or net.
Oh,
these guys are amazing.
Well,
the ref didn't see it,
but it goes.
Got To stop it.
Pardon?
Oh Shit.
Oh my God.
This is an amazing fight.
Come on,
lost.
He said enjoy your wind with one fucking eye
or loss.
He needs to stop this shit.
He
Damn,
he's fuck you.
Super fucked.
Yeah.
This is Barnett.
All fucking says world
submitted.
Dean lister.
He on Gracie here on.
Yes.
Easily.
That is a big feat,
man.
Huge.
It's over right here.
This is nice.
Oh Dude.
This is a fill over and sit in.
Amazing [inaudible] over.
There's no way he's going to get until over.
He's not going to get hit like he's going for the Colorado.
Alaska is a warlock,
so it's got those pipes gone for it.
Again.
This isn't that much room though.
Barnett upset that it got away,
man.
It's got to make a big point to try to get [inaudible] quick funnel grapple with
them.
Oh,
his elbow,
and I'm too,
he's going to open it up so nasty little tender eyes.
It's so nasty.
Do you,
do you remember that time when Arlovski was on the ground and Roy Nelson had
them inside control with a double wrist lock locked in and they stood him up?
Elite elite XC.
That crooked ass organization.
Remember that?
Hell yeah,
I do.
And then
Oh,
oh,
two minutes.
20 seconds.
That's not good.
This is not good.
He's gone back.
He's,
he had choked out.
Yeah.
He's giving up the back and judge,
judge,
Judge Austin,
he's flatten them out.
He's getting the neck that's tapped him.
Josh motherfucking Barnett,
Ladies and gentlemen,
two warriors,
man.
Two legends.
God Damn.
If I was Brennan Shop,
I'd say for sure.
Get off me before he congratulate.
Yeah,
for sure.
Get the fuck outta him.
And let's do this when we get up.
I'm sure his friendship Shit with mounting me.
Great Cardio you would does,
man.
He God,
is he good?
God Damn.
That was a good fight.
Tough as nails,
man.
Josh Brenna is tough as nails,
nails.
That was a Goddamn war.
Chase's whew.
What a fight.
And you know,
all due respect,
he doesn't seem,
he's got great cardio.
He doesn't.
If you looked at his body physically,
isn't that good a shape?
What's good Josh Barnett?
Come on now he's talking about the ledge.
Don't judge a book.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
Brick of fatal voice said that Leah Fate or God,
he's amazing.
Boom.
Oh No.
Oh
he had his hand.
Barnett fucked him up after this.
He went,
oh you won't put them in the fucking eye.
Check this out.
See this our Lassi left to fight there.
I poke thing that was weird.
Maybe see it.
You didn't see it when when they're looking at certain things,
you know and they Ms. Little stuff like that.
It's so hard to stop and reset cause you also stopped the momentum and the fight
and sometimes a guy gets punched in the eye and they'll,
they'll real away as if they got poked.
But if you watch the replay,
it's just the knuckle.
Chuck Dell used to get guys all the time and he would throw these wild,
crazy punches.
He would because of the way the raps are.
And because of the way the gloves are sometimes the chuck was punching you.
He's hitting you like this.
She says these are growing in your eyes.
You can't
stop it because of that.
I mean it's just,
he's just dropping bombs on you.
And sometimes they don't land perfectly with a knuckle or sometimes even with
the knuckle,
the knuckle goes into your eye.
But these,
um,
these things,
right?
These are not covered.
So if you're slinging and you catch someone like this and it goes in the eye,
it feels just like a poke duffing yet.
Stop it.
Yeah.
Probably with Dan Hardee.
Look at him.
He looks like an English team.
Did you see Bruce Buffer?
Fucking white Tux,
some Germany Shit.
That's up for and shit.
Don't bring that here.
Oh,
it shouldn't.
No.
Can't have that here.
How come?
Why does,
which can't do it?
No one talks to his heart.
Those aren't jeans.
Okay.
Powerful,
powerful.
Josh Barnett.
I know we still down,
but
we went for the finish every time.
Please give it up for all up.
Give it up for Andrea last.
You Damn right.
Damn right.
That's like a great sportsman.
This is a crazy division.
It's going to be opened up next week.
We're going to find out what the hell is going on because if Steve Bay can
defend the title,
you know you've got a real champion in your hands and if a Overeem could beat
him,
things get very,
very interesting.
And then you got to put the choke on.
Look at the grip.
Then he got Travis smushed it.
He like punched at it.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Huh?
Well he's a real artist when it comes to submissions.
Josh Barnett and the best of all time,
he knows his shit.
Um,
there's some big ass fights coming up,
dude.
Some big ass rights coming out.
If you were to hit his face,
it would have been different.
Oh,
it's so fucked up man.
But that's,
that's stuff that when you see a guy turning away with this,
all you can holding in his eye like that.
Go ahead and put his,
um,
Jamie,
what's,
um,
the card next weekend?
Get the heavyweights right.
So you got,
you got Steve Bay Overeem,
Verdomme Travis Browne rematch.
I didn't know until today.
Just now that Steve Bay over in with September 10th.
I thought it was today.
I've been really excited about it.
You thought it was on five path?
Yeah.
Why'd you think it was today?
I don't know.
She so you're upset.
I'm a little upset right now.
You thought it was next?
STPA Allister,
look at this very doom and Travis Brown.
Very interesting.
What,
what was the original fight?
Was it,
this is the original file for Bricio was supposed to fight.
Um,
God who pulled out?
Who the fuck pulled out?
Trust Brown was a late replacement.
Oh,
Rothwell Paul pulled out.
that's right.
He pulled out.
Brown got back in.
Right.
Cause he's got his face kicked off by cane,
so he came back in for this rematch,
man.
Travis Brown's in a tough spot.
He loses this one.
Yeah,
it's,
well,
it's also,
you'd taken a gun,
Rhonda.
Pregnant.
How?
Fairly shorter.
There's a notice,
not that short.
Right?
Like four or five weeks,
but it's pretty recent since the fight with 'em Kane.
I know it's tough to get back in.
Then he got that spinning Kod cane.
That's a good question.
Probably a title fight.
I would imagine.
Look at that.
Cm punk versus Mickey galls the third fight of the night.
That's crazy.
That is done before favor and uh,
it,
her,
yeah,
it's after Faber.
Yes.
Sorry.
Favor.
And Jimmy Rivera,
which is an interesting fight,
man.
It's Jimmy Rivera is a tank.
Super tough fight for,
yeah,
he's Wayne.
So dunny well,
he wins a lot.
It's the title.
Yeah.
Well the Dominick Cruz fight was,
you know,
he got dropped in that fight a couple of times.
He got hurt,
which is,
uh,
interesting.
I'll tell you the fight I want to see is a steep avers Kane.
That's the fight matchup wise.
It's such a fun fight.
Very similar styles.
Hey,
what's going on with a tie?
Some off.
He can't get into the country.
I,
yeah,
I don't think so.
That's what I've heard.
Ted Cheyenne Wrestler.
No,
no,
no.
He's not the giant guy.
He's a one 55 or was he 45 or 55 who is he supposed to be fighting?
A 55 read.
Jenny looked that up.
Who is Lansburgh cyborgs funding runs.
Yeah,
he's fighting Nick Lens and that was it would nick lance has been fighting 55
damn.
Who is in verse is Dodson is Co Raisie.
That is God damn crazy.
October 1st.
Portland,
Oregon.
That is madness.
Who's the poor soul fighting Cyborg?
Holy Shit.
That's his name is Lansburgh.
Who's the body back fight and fucking Cyborg in Brazil?
Swimsuit model in Brasilia.
Brasilia that's going to,
you shouldn't be Jamie.
What's her background?
She's a demon hunter.
Landsberg she's all fucking go there with us.
She's a demon on necklace of garlic and a fucking sword with a crucifix of the
bottom of it and still won't help.
You will get knocked the fuck out.
Here's a shield.
Good luck and not enough fight.
Damn man.
That's when I'm good.
Loves can't beat sideboard.
Um,
that's a good question man.
Who is going to be,
yeah.
Marybeth tied them off out of UFC two or three visa issues such as like start
to,
he's very good.
So fucking,
but he's had visa issues for several fights in a row now.
I just don't know why the UFC can't clear that up unless there's some weird shit
for sure.
Somebody did one of what the problem is.
I don't understand visas,
man.
I don't understand like who gets them and who doesn't,
you know,
I think right now it's a little tough.
It was different grind.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I wonder,
I wonder what,
why did they decline those things,
man?
You know,
I'm a wonder.
I don't know what it is,
but too bad.
Cause he could fight his ass off.
So good.
Yeah.
He's very good man.
Very good.
And you'll look at that whole card.
That's a Ooh,
Ian Mccall and Ray Borg Boys.
Ready to forgot that Ray Borg is no joke.
That's interesting.
Who's on the flight path?
Uh,
batch go and he answered me.
Darryl's Shawn Spencer.
That's a good fight.
That should be next weekend.
So,
uh,
what else is going on?
You are.
You're calling that fight off.
It's Habibi chimp.
I'm there next week.
Yeah.
Powerful Cleveland.
See Ya.
See You fuckers Cleveland.
He's going to finally have one that's deep based town.
It's going to be interesting man.
They're going to come out in droves for him.
Hopefully.
Yeah,
no,
it's going to be,
it's a,
it's a very interesting fight man.
Steve Bay is no fucking joke.
It's a toss up for me,
but Alistair Overeem is so good striking.
He's so clever and sneaky and now the way he fights,
he like moves around you and doesn't take any chances until he sees an opening.
Then he snipes on you and he,
you know,
meal CIC has got to be able to counter that and if he can end clip him and hurt
them the way Rothwell did,
then the fight becomes interesting.
You also look at the way Steve Bay like almost terminators forward.
You know what I'm saying?
How that mean when this pace,
like you do jds,
you can't really do that with over Overeem.
There's no trading like that really.
Well,
it's going to be hard if he gets hit with leg kicks like right away because
Alistair Overeem has some fucking for Roche's leg kicks and kicks.
He also throws that left kick to the body.
He switches stances a lot.
He can do a lot of different shit in their striking wise.
His knees are fucking horrific.
And then his grappling.
Yeah.
And his grappling,
his credit,
but we forget about it.
Yeah.
Is grappling is good.
It's a very good,
he won the European Abu Dhabi qualifier.
Correct.
And he's a,
I think there's a first guy to submit veto before Jon Jones did.
He submitted him with a good team back into pride days.
Now he's no joke,
man.
Yeah.
People forget about the Johnson versus boys.
It's hot fun hall brunch.
That's very good.
Yeah.
Y'All,
we riot hall almost got the Anderson Silva fight.
Right.
And Anderson hurt himself.
He'll Brooks is a wrestling superstar.
It's interesting,
this whole thing.
So interesting that it's taken so long.
Yeah.
I mean I uh,
I don't hate on the guy for pursuing something new.
Who am I to hate on a guy for doing something to him out of his lane.
You know,
that's my life.
But Cowboy and I were making fun of him the other day for being a straight edge
for not drinking.
People got so mad.
Yeah,
they got so mad.
He's never,
he's never been drunk.
No drinking,
no drugs,
no steroids,
no nothing.
And we were like,
all right,
good luck with all that.
How Fun.
People get so mad.
Like folks relax.
You know?
If you don't want to drink,
you don't have to drink.
I'm not saying you should drink and I'm not,
not drinking right now.
Dumped stone cold sober.
I didn't drink at all last night either.
I go many,
many days without drinking.
You don't have to drink,
but I only drink here.
I,
I almost don't drink.
It's a fun,
Damn.
His shirt was super corny,
but you don't have to do it.
He's got a lot of guts though.
I'm not mad at his girl either.
Well,
it's also like how many options does he have?
It's really interesting when you think the fact that this guy was competing in
the WWE and he's going to fight at one 70 it's kind of crazy because you know
one 70 is small.
It's not very big.
A big way cut for him.
What does he walk around that?
No,
it's not a big way.
He's not a big guy,
but it's even more interesting that this guy was able to compete as a
professional.
Yeah.
Like on television,
like to do all that stuff against guys that they must be way bigger than him.
Cause he's not a big guy.
No,
he's not a huge guy.
He's going to get fucked up.
Are you Eddie Bravo.
How dare you question the,
you've been trying to look at the striking.
It's fucking elite.
You will train in three years.
How bacteria with Joe Rogan to elite.
It's elite world class.
Well it is.
He's trying to help world class level and he's,
look,
he's the guy who's taking a big fucking chance.
We can mock them all their stack that at the end of the day you got to respect
the fact that he's going to do it.
I don't think too many people would do it.
Well,
I mean his level,
I don't know man.
Also,
I'm very curious to see how he responds to the pressure me to,
because you can't heat.
That's the one thing that bothers me is I heard people go,
oh,
are you worried about the crowd and the UFC?
Jailers,
the real needles.
I've been in front of big,
big crowds.
It's no different.
I'm telling you it's different.
I played football and way bigger crowds.
Fighting's completely different.
Even though you wrestled,
it's one on one.
It does not,
but the is not real.
See,
he hasn't done anything.
Competition was,
no pressure.
Didn't do karate tournaments,
didn't wrestle,
didn't kickbox.
There was,
there's no Jujitsu tournaments in his past,
so the only competition is that he's had really realistically are smokers inside
the gym,
which I believe they put him through a few.
How they did.
How did he get into the WWE?
Like how did that happen?
What's that story?
He says he's not a big guy.
Was He an actor?
How did he do it?
Question.
It's a good question.
And when he did that was something special about him.
If he's a small dude,
it's just taking this guy,
you know,
he's been on any steroids and,
and he's doing pro wrestling because Todd happened.
She's a good talker.
But if you watch is like,
I mean he's good a entertainer,
but if you watch like it's pro wrestling,
like there's guys that are in pro wrestling,
they're just freak athletes,
you know,
and they can somersault,
flip over their opponents and land behind them and then spin them around and get
them a figure for a toe hold or whatever the fuck they guy.
He's not one of those guys.
He was the guy that jumped off and did flips and status quo
Mexican mass one those guys the craziest,
they'll sponsor you in the legs and flip you buy your own neck.
Cause it's not as staff to do crazy shit.
That's just a law.
If you're going to be tiny and Rhett,
you gotta be fucking,
he was like the outcasts and Deb Darby.
He was like the the the anti man.
Like would it go against Vince?
Vince Mcmahon,
the businessman.
That was his whole spiel like one,
what is this jumping through the air?
It's going to land on a table or are we showing them,
make them do crazy shit there,
but that doesn't mean he's jumping onto a cushion.
How crazy that my kids do that?
My mom,
because it's a place down the street from here,
this trampolines and they have cushions.
He jumped on the sky zone.
Yeah,
all the time.
This is a,
I mean it's kind of funny,
but at the end of the day,
it's not like Brock Lesnar.
You look at Brock Lesnar and by the way,
just he would move around and he'd be like,
I like to see that guy fight for real.
You look at this guy and he's like a reasonable athlete.
Like you look at his body,
he's like a reasonably athletic guy who's,
you know,
it looks like it works out,
but you like,
you look at his legs,
you don't go,
Jesus.
I bet that guy could jump over the fucking moon,
you know?
Well,
not,
yeah,
he's like a like a,
he's not a big guy.
He's not real athletic.
Yeah.
He just like your everyday average Jimmy guy and said,
cool.
Let's see him fight.
He has a big name.
Hey,
you never,
never wants tuning in.
Yeah.
I mean,
I do know he won't be the one 70 pound champ of the world.
We do know that.
How dare you?
How dare you question with a man to do that either look at him next to the rock.
It looks like the rocks about to eat him.
I will eat you.
I would love to see the rock fight in the smaller than the rock.
Oh,
he's way smaller than I'm doing.
Not In that picture.
Wow.
Look at those arms.
They look similar.
I got big arms for sure.
The camera thing.
It's a perspective issue.
Have you seen any of the,
I mean,
I'm not degrading his body or anything like that,
but if you look at most of the pictures of him wrestling,
like go to that one on the upper left,
right hand side,
go down,
scroll down a little Jamie,
that next column and there go to the right,
right there.
I click.
Yeah,
you can tell you wasn't taking cow.
It's like he's a fit guy.
He's in shape,
you know.
But I mean,
the difference between him and a rock or absolutely Lesnar like rock is like a
big powerful athlete.
A guy works out a lot.
He's,
yeah,
he's a Jack fucking giant dude.
But Brock moves around,
their guy knows how to kill people.
There's a total difference.
Like when he grabs guys and what happened recently,
he broke some guy's head open with elbows and elbow.
Yeah,
it's all on purpose.
Yeah.
But it was a real shot.
I would think they have a lot of scar tissue up there from k taking chairs to
the head and stuff.
So if you're going to open a professional wrestler,
do it there.
Jamie,
you know this is true.
He supposedly got into a real fight with somebody backstage that didn't know
that the thing that was going out in the ring was staged to Oh really?
Okay.
I got mad that you went too far,
bro.
But he didn't let everybody knew about it.
So they planned on doing that in advance.
So the guy in the back was like,
you went too far,
bro.
He didn't know about it and he didn't know it was staged.
Is he retarded?
2016 has he not know it's staged.
It's pro wrestling,
right?
Supposedly Broccoli's there's none for going off script,
which is part of that motherfucker is crazy.
That's off script motherfucker.
Roid raging mother fucker.
Yeah,
it's a,
he's a big fella.
It's too bad,
dude.
Yeah.
You know,
you saw the,
I don't know what kind of a suspension they're gonna give him,
but they're talking about not giving them that much of a suspension.
Fuck,
I'm gonna get the Hillary Clinton treatment because this is a straight Clomid.
Doesn't shut the fuck up.
Different.
The judge,
what the fuck is he talking about?
Coming back and fighting another fight.
Oh yes.
I'm sure.
I'm sure he would made a ton of money.
Crazy.
Marley didn't get beat up,
you know,
fuck mark hung control them on the ground.
Nothing that would be next.
I Bet I was going about to say that'd be an interesting,
that would be very,
and Jon Jones,
Brock Lesnar facing potential shorter suspensions from Usada.
Listen,
they need to just throw you sato and he'll go,
look,
we,
we uh,
we proved the point.
I think we got it.
He got it.
But how does it work?
Cause you it up.
You sort of take the place
of the commission now in testing.
No,
no,
it's not that they take the place of the commission.
I believe the commissions are still within their rights to test fighters.
You'd have to actually look that up to make sure that's correct.
But the most important thing is the UFC is testing fighters all year round.
You have to give notice of where you are constantly all the time.
So they're testing you,
whether you're in competition with your attic competition,
they're testing you randomly,
the shown at your house at seven o'clock in the morning.
And if they catch you,
they're going to suspend you.
But who do they report it to?
Joe?
That's a good question.
Who Do they report to and who makes the decision?
Cause you saw it as hired by the UFC.
Like dill,
not us commission the Commission.
So,
and you cite a test,
you,
you get tested by two different bodies,
right?
But remember you sought us,
they don't test the whole card.
Selective testing are not nuts.
You saw to the commission.
But the question is,
and this is what we talked grow Scott Coker.
So when you sign a test and who's an employee of the UFC,
the UFC hired Usada tests or athletes.
Nothing to do with the commission now.
So,
so when you Sada,
let's say they find Lesnar Lawsky,
you know,
random names.
Let's say cm punk fail the test.
Do they go,
Hey Dana,
he failed a test.
Like how's it work?
What's the exact steps?
What's this?
These our exact question on firing the kid.
No one answered it.
Really?
What's the chain of p?
What's the path to like in Dana?
Go?
Fuck.
All right,
well it's just Molly.
Let's not spend it for that.
Or he was,
you know,
it's this.
He's our main event.
Let's not do that.
I don't think I'd have to Dana or Holly.
There's no way I had to like to party.
It's weird to think about.
I don't know.
I'd love to.
I'll see.
There's no way Dana or whoever's late will.
It would be Dan as going,
well,
he just spent for that.
Let's do this.
You know,
I think when it comes to Bella [inaudible],
the commission still checks,
but it's a random thing and yeah.
Well they can't be checking that.
They can't be checking that much.
Well,
no mission for fight week.
You get,
I mean it's,
it can for sure.
Well,
how does that guy,
Michael [inaudible],
whatever his name is,
get away with it.
Bobby Lashley.
Yeah,
he's fighting Michael Chiseling.
He's standing.
Michael Chiseling.
He's fighting in places that don't have commissions like Oklahoma,
wherever.
Oh,
certainly.
Certain states don't have no commission.
So then Bella tore the UFC is responsible in deciding what they want to test or
not.
Like when bell tour went to England,
there's no commission.
There was no fight commission testing them.
So belt or had their own testing,
which has again,
how's that work?
Shoot.
It's interesting.
That's very interesting.
And it fell as though no commission.
Do you think
she'll be able to do whatever the fuck they want?
It's their organization.
If they don't want to hire you Sada and they don't want to do it that way.
Let's see what it's like you do with the old.
Yup.
Well we still deal with,
you're talking about pride,
talking about a strike force to UFC pre days.
Talking about Uber in verse Broccoli.
Well,
without mentioning names too,
you can see set a difference
in some people's bodies in the UFC.
Now they've cracked down on this shit.
No more.
The new bream.
Yeah.
Well maybe.
TRT TV tour.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
That was a weird one because it was so transparent because it was TRT.
I mean he was taking it.
It was legally prescribed heavy towards number one on that.
He's number one also number one for like the poster boy for results like Jesus,
where do I sign like fuck,
hello civic.
If you show a kid a video,
I'm like,
dad,
why the fuck would I do?
I have no sun,
no argument.
Like a human and Elian made a baby.
Even Tanner,
he was Tanner and the Mohawk,
the whole thing comes out like crosses shaved into his head.
Uber religious.
Jesus ain't putting that testosterone in your blood son.
Yeah,
well that was one of the things that he said after he got off of it is that he
has a wholly supplement that he doesn't need TLC and the one working out for it.
It took a while for the holy supplement to really hand the blood of Christ.
I'm still fucking waiting.
Yeah,
just pray every day.
Get Jack who's widening going to fight?
That's what I want to know.
He's fighting in New York though.
Well he should be,
but I mean damn.
He was like in the mix.
Now they're talking about rumble versus John Jones for a shot.
At the title and um,
they're talking about,
uh,
does that supposed to be at Madison Square Garden?
Is that they were saying that's what they're saying,
but I'm so wouldn't be Rockhold Weidman too,
right?
If Wyman two would be fucking awesome because you love is being the Henderson
for the title in England happening.
That's October.
That's in Manchester member.
You would have Weidman Vuss Rockhold right.
It's not a bad idea.
But then what do you put,
what do you do with Yoel Romero?
He's still in the mix.
Very much so.
Yeah.
Not really.
He's out.
He's next.
Not when it comes to those guys,
man.
What do you,
what do you mean hard to market?
You can mark it the fuck out.
You're not going to put uol verse one of these guys in New York.
It's a huge,
huge Madison Square Garden.
He's coming off suspension.
Rockhold Weidman.
We're going to watch,
let me tell you something.
I will see Yoel Romero fight against fucking or Nivo to wow.
Rashad Evans,
maybe Rashad Evans versus y'all were okay.
Rashad's fighting Tim [inaudible].
What is this?
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
The only one that's supposedly confessed Jesus Christ.
Wow.
That's interesting.
So it Kennedy's back in full training mode.
Oh yeah.
Cause he's been,
he's always interested.
He's,
he's been like still serving well,
he was in kill mode.
Yeah.
This is,
this is a fist fight mode.
This is easy mode for him.
Get ready for a fight.
Yeah.
What is he talking about?
A guy living in an intense light.
Tough fight for a shot.
I like the matchup though.
It's interesting and see if he could make that one 85 cut.
Cause he was not,
he's not a big two.
Oh,
Fiverr.
And he was carrying around quite a bit of muscle.
Um,
I'm surprised Tim went,
went,
went on with the Reebok deal.
I wonder what did it for him?
I don't know.
Maybe
he wants to fight.
Maybe he just wants to fight.
But yeah,
man,
it's a,
it's to see what can happen without the Reebok Dia Without Usada over at
Bellator.
And they're slowly starting to get top talent.
You know.
I mean,
now they've got Benson,
they've got Rory.
Rory voiced by far the biggest,
by far,
the best.
Right.
Young can still has a lot fight leftover.
Yeah.
And Ben's right up there within Benson Henderson too many,
too many long,
and he's had some wars.
He slipped a little bit.
I mean,
he might,
he might still be elite of the elite,
but at one point in time he's accomplished more than any of them.
I mean,
he's,
he was,
yeah.
I mean,
he was a champ.
Yeah,
that'd be,
see Chubby
casts even kind of talk that,
he kind of hinted that,
you know,
he's not,
he's coming to the end of sort of what he considers his MMA career.
I only do it for so long,
but he didn't hit that.
Now.
He still,
he thinks he's going to be champ and he's also fighting for the belt.
Sure.
He's fighting the Chandler for the belt,
which is a tough fucking five tough fucking chairs and nightmare.
He's dangerous.
And Ben hasn't let you know.
I Love Ben.
He knows,
but he hasn't looked that great and part the tour lost his first fight,
his last fight with pit bull.
Not a great pilot.
I'm actually losing that fight until people got hurt.
Rory is going to take a whole year off for his nose.
And that's from Robbie Lawler?
Yeah,
Wonderboy to mash them up.
Fight.
Well the Wonderboy open it up,
but as Robbie Lawler broke it so bad and that fight that he broke it twice more
and training for wonder boy just kept,
keeps breaking was,
I don't know if he gets surgery for that,
like what do you do?
He thinks just time,
like he had the proper surgery,
but he keeps rushing back and it's just not getting better and breathe.
If he had the proper surgery and he went and got smashed up again,
it's probably got to be cleared out with true clear up again.
So maybe that's why he's taking a year.
That is such an issue with fighters because they get,
they want to get their nose fixed,
but if you do get your nose fixed,
you really shouldn't get punched in it for a while.
But if you don't get your nose fixed and you can't breathe out of your fucking
nose,
you have to do it.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a real weird,
fun.
Vandelay had the craziest solution.
Make your nose bigger.
Go to get surgery.
Take a chunk of cartilage.
Your ribbon.
Make me a big nose.
Breathe out.
Yeah.
Gimme that Lebron James knows.
I'll take them the Bron.
He got this like extra chunk in his nose where his nose was like it did.
It was bigger than it was before.
His fighting career.
He got a nose job.
Let's be real here.
He got a nose.
Job is bigger.
Yes.
Which is cray just written.
No one's ever,
Hollywood is like,
do what?
I want it bigger.
Bigger with my nostrils like this.
So the air's like Ram,
Ram air,
right.
Nostrils.
Like he's got a hood scoop on the life if you want.
I guess.
Man,
it's fucking nuts.
We think about it.
That is funny,
man.
It is funny.
Yeah.
He's a,
he had to get all sorts of stuff done.
He had to get his eyebrows cut down.
He had so much scar tissue around his eyes that his eyes were sagging.
Yeah.
He's,
well,
he got all this scar tissue cut and then they pull it up.
Let's say a before and after when you could see that he's got deep scars all
around his eyes,
like Vandelay has been in some fucking wars,
legend,
Legend.
And then on top of that,
he comes from shoot to box and they're sparring sessions.
Nobody spars.
Like they used to spar hell today.
Nobody does it like that.
They used to knock each other out for fun.
You can't,
there's an old,
it's an old story of Vandelay four and after,
oh,
that's not a good one.
That's not even a good one.
Cause that right ones,
not the new one.
Well the right one is,
uh,
the one on the right hand side is relaxed.
Like after the surgery,
go,
go above,
they're like,
they're like there,
he could see like it's,
you got to see him like right after the surgery.
That's his nose number three.
He's at three different noses.
Like it says one,
two,
three.
You see that Jamie knows one then it was too,
yeah,
that,
so what that is is that,
that's right after surgery and that's when it's a little bit more relaxed I
guess.
But yeah,
he uh,
he had to get sliced down.
That guys had some crazy wars.
Him and shogun fought over a pit bull puppy supposedly,
and he knocked shogun out and took the puppy.
Like they,
they made a contacts.
If I knock you out,
I get the puppy for free.
If you knocked me out,
I'll give you,
you know,
whatever,
whatever you're asking me and shit.
She actually do a really good Vander Lee impression,
but I do know why it's in the old,
this is a good day of dawn in the Nevada.
This does the athletic commission.
What they've done is,
uh,
it's not good.
It's almost as good as Calvin.
Just like them.
They fucked him,
man.
He,
he might've got fuck more than any MMA fighter ever.
Yeah.
They banned him for life,
for life,
for life.
And he won.
He,
so they made,
they threw it out,
but now he doesn't have a license.
He doesn't have a timeline.
He doesn't have it.
And they're talking about him fighting.
They were talking about him fighting fade or in,
in Japan in like December even had posters and shit.
I don't know if that's ever going to happen.
When does it guy got after all that damage?
Take Stop.
I mean that's probably fade or I'll want to fight.
Fight the good fight.
It's like a Brazilian artist.
Well,
day the whites back to to pride.
Did you want to hear a fucking crazy story I heard about Jake Ellenberger pro.
This is from his camp.
So Jake,
after his last fight,
have you heard this?
No.
Jake,
after his last fight gets cut.
Joe Civil closet like Devin.
Oh yeah know.
Cut.
Jake flies to Vegas,
shows up with UFC headquarters.
Meet with Dana.
He's in his office.
He's like,
I need one more man.
You got to give me one of my fight monsters.
My head wasn't right.
I have all the shit going on.
He got to give me one more dance like I can't,
man,
you've lost whatever,
400 last five it just thinking happening,
gets up leaves and Jake goes,
I'm not going anywhere and I'm not going to give me another fight.
I'm not doing anything.
Are you staying at leaves?
Tell us all shit comes back to,
it's still in his office.
They,
Jesus Christ.
Amen.
Fine.
One more.
One more fucking shot.
Pays go by day skill by Joe Civil calls,
his manager,
his manager Morgan,
who I know really well.
And he goes,
all right man,
we get your wife fucking fight.
Uh,
we got Matt Brown and his,
his magic goes,
Jesus man,
Matt Brown.
I don't know if we do have anyone else and Joe pseudos.
No,
that's the fight.
Just forget it.
He doesn't have a fight.
Hangs up many more.
He was like,
no,
no.
We'll fucking take it.
And they calls Jake and then off.
See Jake goes in there.
Terrible matchup for him.
Just starches.
Matt Brown knocks him down with a right hand,
takes him off his feet and then liver kicks him.
Great story,
man.
Crazy amazing when they told us goosebumps.
Good for you.
Good for you man.
Damn.
Desperation can sometimes breed great success.
God probably also started working with nick.
Curse on,
you know,
Nick [inaudible] who's a strength and conditioning trainer.
Speed of sport.
He's Martin Marinovich,
his disciple and uh,
he's the guy that's done Joe Schilling.
He handles providing a cough.
Uh,
Aaron Peko like a lot of elite athletes go to him.
It's really like pretty revolutionary strength and conditioning ideas and uh,
he worked with them and like really built up his training and built up his
endurance and did a lot of Plyo,
some shit with them.
And for Jacob,
I'll see his fighting just monsters.
We seem to be a little bit of mental thing.
He's been fighting forever.
So finding the best of the best.
Yes.
It's hard to first find the UFC is against Carlos condit.
Yeah,
man.
Remember he knocked out Jake shields,
knocked him out.
Starts to him.
Was it his first fight in the UFC?
Was it [inaudible] first fight in the UFC was Ellenberger I want to say conduits
first.
Frighten the Kim Wc Ellenberger his first fight in the UFC.
Then I want to know,
I was interesting.
It wasn't Nate,
right?
No.
Ellenberger is a beast,
man.
I was way down the road.
Remember we need knocked out a Palae.
Yes.
Outside of the UFC.
Kol Palae with one punch.
I was like,
cray power man.
Crazy pay.
Landy,
Carlos Condit Carlsbad was his first fight as well.
So I think it was Carlos his first fight as well.
Hmm.
Decision Split.
Real close fight.
Oof.
And remember,
remember when,
uh,
Jake Ellenberger beach shields?
That's the same week shields dad passed away and he was thinking about not
fighting.
They took the flight and just got starts not to take anything away from that
fight.
He was super close with his dad to SuperZoo imagine.
No,
I can't.
It's hard to imagine how hard.
Imagine fighting right after losing your dad like that.
Like your motivation would be out the window.
His Dad was his manager too,
I think.
Yeah,
it's Obama ran.
Yeah.
What is this rumor Conor Mcgregor versus GSP at two oh five.
Where are you hearing this?
I was looking around for a rumor mill stuff for that fight and uh,
there's supposedly a big fight announcement is all I saw.
And then I saw big McGregor fight announced
awesome.
[inaudible] get wrestle.
Fuck.
Just the roof right now compared to get
prepared to get French fucked for 25 minutes.
Give me my fucking money back.
It would be interesting man,
because Connor is fast as fuck.
And at least in that first round,
while he's exploding with those ridiculous sprint punches that he lands,
he lands those counter shots on you and they're so fast and Peter's not slow.
He's not so way,
way too smart to,
and he's big.
He's a big boy and can grapple with the best of him.
And his natural walk around weight is a solid 20 plus pounds heavier.
Solid.
Yeah.
He's probably in a lease in the high one 1800% and Konner weighed one 68 against
Nate,
which you gotta assume that that's him not really cutting weight.
He's just really fit for economists.
And everyone knows I'm a,
uh,
the biggest Connor fan.
But you look at the matchup that 55,
besides 45,
which you can't really make him more,
but you look at 55 and then the super flights just not great man.
Well,
they're talking about doing him and Eddie Alvarez that has no picnic.
No,
I know,
and that's as easy as matchup at 55 and funds easiest.
No,
just go through the top five.
Bring up the top five.
Jimmy.
I went through this slow down.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
I could not imagine that the champion would be as easiest style stylistically.
I don't think that's an easy fight for anybody,
Monster.
Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
It's not good for comics.
A rough fight for it,
but you think that list the least out of the top five.
I'm like,
fuck sakes,
man.
He doesn't want to fight Khabib.
Well,
dos Anjos is going to fight Tony motherfucking Ferguson.
That's the both.
Those both those two are top,
top those angels.
Tony Ferguson in Mexico.
[inaudible]
right guys,
look at the,
look at the top five fam.
Hey,
get that.
Yeah.
Have even heard of Macra met off is a monster.
That's a seed.
Dosign geos and Tony Ferguson or locked in a in a death fucking match for the
number one winter.
Even the winter that are either of those guys.
Even the loser fights conduct a fucking tough flight and Barboza.
Well,
here's the thing about Barboza Barboza his kicks are out of this fucking war
lightly.
Like he might be,
but he's been caught before.
He's been cracked,
cracked them and took his back and Donald Cerrone and him would be k.
Dot.
Donald would taken a loss is not fighting 55 anymore.
He's going to keep fighting at one 70 so I don't even know why they got him
ranked there cause I think he's top 10 right now at Walter was seven.
Yeah,
isn't he?
Yeah.
Donald Cerrone seven it's interesting.
He's top 10 in both.
He's fine.
Better than he's ever fought.
I mean,
he's just incredible.
How dare you haven't before Neil Mag?
No,
no,
no.
How dare you?
I th I think,
I think you,
I think Donald's,
especially after that last wind should be number five in that line.
He beat Edson Barboza.
Yes he did.
But he beat him at a lightweight and now he's not really fighting at lightweight
anymore.
But yeah,
you've got a good point because Barboza was listed as number four,
but Barboza is looks sensational,
especially in his last fight against Gilbert Melendez.
Barboza is just off the charts technical head to head.
I know,
I agree.
And then before that,
his fight with Pettis,
but the fact that Donald is semi retired from that division.
Yeah.
You got to give Barboza a little bit of a bond.
You see,
you see my thing?
Joy?
Like you look at it all right.
It could be fuck sakes.
Dos Anjos Good God Tony Person,
not great.
Nate Diaz at 55.
He's better at 55 thing with 70.
Why?
Uh,
I think it's natural for him.
I think he's gonna be faster or better cardio.
I think it's a thought.
It's a tough fight.
Maybe all I'm saying for Connor 55,
it's a,
if you're as management,
you're like,
God damn man.
There's no like,
you know what I'm saying?
There's a lot of killers looking for easy fights.
I think he wants big.
Didn't say that.
If you want big money fight Floyd Mayweather.
You do a super fight with these guys.
Yeah,
Mcgregor would be awesome.
That'd be awesome.
As to Manav ranked 15th at one seven days won the welterweight division is
insane.
It is insane.
That's insane.
And then did you see how good Lorens Larkin locked against Neil Magni could
lord.
And how is he wrote the whore?
How's he ranked lower than new magnate?
Y Z nine in Neil's eight cause this reading suck.
That's terrible.
He just ran through Neil magic fingers do these.
But he literally ran through them in the first round like fucking warm like a
knife to warm butter.
Just starch.
How it is man ranked below him.
That is insane right there Kelvin.
Number five by the way,
to Nauv beat Neil magnet or excuse me,
Lorens Larkin.
So Tumen off one a decision against Lorens Larkin and he's down there at number
15 where's Lorens just destroyed Neil Magni and he's at nine and magnesium eight
that these rankings are retarded.
They're so bad.
They're probably old.
I doubt they're old now.
They're not all cause they have the up and down side.
Well this is what it is.
These journalists,
do you know how these things are established?
Journalists,
a bunch of journalists give their top pick and half of them are drunk and not
paying attention.
They're doing drugs.
Well half of them are jacking off to their favorite fighter.
Well,
it doesn't make any sense.
Like those ratings don't make any sense to me off being at 15 Lorens Larkin who
he beat being ranked way above him.
And then Neil Magdi been above him when he just ballooned magni out of the water
and the first round.
Does it make any sense when they're getting base guys pay off the rankings and
fighters?
Like what the fuck is going on here?
Dana was like,
just fucking with you.
There's going to be Reebok.
Yeah.
Just fucking with you.
We ain't doing that.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
It's uh,
the,
the rankings and the money and all that jazz.
It's just what a,
what a mess.
But yeah,
for,
for economy gets tough at 55.
I'd love to see him fight you though that.
I agree that the fight he could win,
that's probably the Beta.
That's probably the fight and then what happens if he gets the belt then he
would probably defend against Khabib are good luck with all that.
Yeah,
that's a disaster.
I don't think anyone wants to fight.
Could be no one is timing the congress.
She was the entire fucking their way.
They're just hoping that he keeps training like a fucking werewolf and then
tears another knee or blows his back out.
That's it.
Everybody has a stay back while that guy whips himself frenzy and every he's
training his coke.
That bitch is just on the Arrow.
That's his whole camp.
He's just erudite.
Where's that crazy Russian hat and jumps in the fucking octagon.
He just jumps with a sauna into the frozen lake.
I don't people to talk and Blake,
I just have a bubble around aerodyne crazy fashion hat.
This is use to do spray build up that cardio.
He's a fucking nightmare when you watch him fight dos Anjos and like you see how
dos Anjos just overwhelms guys with grappling and pressure and then have eve
just racked off rag doll to grapple check the show.
This is my favorite things to do to break people.
Cheer was grappling.
Grizzly bears.
You fuck check this.
Does he have a fight coming up?
Uh,
is he scheduled to fight?
anybody who doesn't have anything?
No,
he doesn't have any.
We'll probably injuries.
I'm an asshole out or something.
He's always,
he's,
I think he's healthy.
He gets her.
Well I hope he is.
He won a fight recently against the guy who took the fight on real,
real short notice and it was straight your hand.
Miller bully beat downs.
Now it was pretty ferocious beat down,
but he,
you know,
he looked,
uh,
you know,
he looked like it was good for him to get that fight under his belt,
but he did look like a killer.
It's a killer.
I mean his,
his grappling.
So next level,
he's very strong.
Healing him then trains hard do,
did you,
did you see his video of him in Russia doing like a signing for Reebok?
No,
it was like Tom Cruise Shit.
I'm sure they freaked the fuck out dude.
Anytime I post anything about the UFC,
my Instagram like comments get swarmed with Khabib.
Khabib Time Khabib,
Tyler.
Oh my God.
And other parts of the world like here he is.
He see like this fucking the high level smash and grappling this guy has.
You're right Joe.
This was good.
This was good for him cause he had a lot of time off with the injuries.
Darrel Horcher and to get that fight on the under his belt feel good too.
He does whatever he wants.
He's so powerful when it comes to his grappling play this fight,
play him versus dos Anjos full fight.
He's just,
he's,
he's a Goddamn Werewolf man.
Even the weight like leaps in and throws punches.
He's so ferocious.
It's hard to stay healthy when you train like that though.
I don't,
I don't know what a guy,
some guys are fucking figuring out.
Hey yeah,
answer me this.
How come they can show this on youtube?
Is it because it's in like a little window?
The tricks they play so there's
this faded line over here.
This is also going to add to like tricking the computer inside the truck on it.
They add an interest.
Definitely illegal.
Yeah,
it's definitely illegal.
scoot up ahead so we don't have to watch them walk in.
Yeah,
it's interesting man.
This guy has been more plagued with injuries than any elite fighter other than
Dominick Cruz like Dominick Cruz and him probably take the cake with Dominick.
Cruz had how many fights before he started getting all these injuries.
Like he hasn't had that many fights in the UFC and he's undefeated,
which is really crazy.
No one at this level's undefeated.
Never.
Madoff is the only guy that's undefeated just because in the,
funny enough though,
but it's the fucking pressure.
Look at this guy only moves forward.
Just massive pressure.
Constant pressure just but good distance control just outside the range but
always putting that pressure on you.
Skinny dose and it's a good kick to the body.
But yeah,
a lot skinnier.
Dos Anjos this is the fight that probably got them to start lifting weights and
drink watermelon juice
Boone's look at this,
look at this,
this like,
it carries him around and he drags him to the ground.
Dude,
his grappling,
his so next level,
combat sambo,
my friend,
master of sport,
world champion.
Just so fucking brutal and this style that he does,
it's like,
it makes sense that this guy gets injured a lot because his style is pedal to
the metal and you,
you gotta train like this.
There's no way he doesn't train like this.
So if you're training like this all the time,
you're dealing with little injuries,
a little micro injuries to get exacerbated and then your fucking knees below
out.
Let's get the fuck out of here boys.
Let's wrap this bitch up.
Let's bring it home.
Bring it home.
Go three rounds,
three rounds.
I always quiet.
I always feel like I'm particularly quiet because I'm watching the fights.
Did he stop him and the third one?
No,
no.
He just overwhelmed.
Decision.
Yeah.
Overwhelmed them.
Just kept us,
kept us on.
Joe's defending.
It's all he was doing was defending towards the end of the fight.
Appy Hobby.
I've worn this hat several times.
Twice sweaty had it,
puts it on me when we,
when I interview him after he wins,
I forget what that thing is called.
The big crazy hats.
Bush guy think is it really Babushka but are you sure?
Look it up.
What is that thing called?
Find out what that things called.
That might be just a wig,
but I think it's a Babushka.
No,
no,
no.
It's a,
it's a warm hat man.
It's like,
like probably like lambs for sheep for something like that.
There it is.
What is it called?
No,
that's not it.
Well by boosts cause a grandmother.
But this goes,
I think the hat head scarf tied under the chin.
Okay.
Images.
Well what is that?
What?
Just what?
Google neuroma Grumet offs hat and just for by Bush because open have the name
of it.
I don't think it's a Babushka Bro.
I think it kind of looks like a Babushka,
but I think it's a c is that a Babushka?
Okay,
well we'll just Google neuroma.
Go Madoff's hat.
Because he comes from a very particular place.
Dagestan and they have their own kind of hat.
Is it Dagestan?
I could see right there.
I've even heard of met off hat.
I be Pat.
Maybe it's just called the Hubby Bat.
Find out what it is.
There it goes.
The Pakistani distinctive hat,
the heritage behind his distinctive hat pup.
Pekka p a.
P.
A.
K.
H.
A man means hat.
They call it half the right that are in fact people.
It says a very shaggy wild popped back up and pop Paka simply means hat on board
and lamb for Jesus.
So when is he,
what is it?
Onboard lamp.
Unborn lamb.
What?
He made the hat.
Where are the for of unborn lamp.
How's that?
Does that right?
All right.
Yeah,
so it's super soft.
They give birth to them like that.
No,
they take it out.
Doesn't make any sense.
They can take it out of the womb and they take that for that's already there
cause it's extra soft.
But does that,
does that make sense?
That they could get that much further along inside the wound?
They do that stuff too.
Like so one car company on camera was was using cow fetus because the leather
was super sa shut the fuck.
All right.
God,
what company affinity and no way animals,
they'd have to kill bees.
They were using,
they were using cow fetus,
cow fetuses.
Like it's in the womb and it's so,
so that's pretty fucking brutal if you think about it.
And affinity was doing that.
I believe it or not,
it was some kind of,
some concrete ensued.
I will.
You're going to get to yeah,
they're going to see me because they waited for the academy born then they used
it.
Wow.
How weird.
Huh?
Pretty well.
You know that's what Lam is.
I was trying to explain something to like what's the difference in sheep and
lamb?
Lamb,
baby sheep baby sheet.
Someone looked at me like,
what?
Ah Huh.
Yeah.
You didn't know that condoms are made from baby shit.
Damn,
that's,
this is a depiction of lamb and a sheep.
Like if you,
if you eat lamb,
you're eating a baby sheet,
but if you eat mutton,
you're eating a sheet.
That's right.
So like the people and like Scotland,
eight and Scotland,
they're,
they're eating that stuff.
That's a different,
let's a much more,
don't kill the lambs.
Amy.
Don't fuck with Liz.
I slept on it.
The good for you.
Those fuck at us.
It's really like a very healthy protein.
Very easy to adjust to.
A lot of people don't fuck with Glam or pay grade and he paid on the bacon thing
and hit Rom.
I hate putting say,
yeah,
I like Bacon,
but I don't like domesticated pigs.
It the whole pig industry.
It bothers me because pigs are smart and they're all penned up like that.
It was like there's only one way to get bacon.
Outside of that.
You've got to find a dude who's a farmer who's ethical.
You got to find like a guy who was a farmer who's given,
they're like,
this is orange and stuff with,
yeah,
Joel Salitan.
What he does is he has a,
he moves his pay as a giant piece of land and he moves his pigs around with
electric fences.
So he sets up an electric perimeter and then he moves.
It sets up a new electric perimeter and he moves it and says it.
So they're constantly forging like regular pay,
but they're constantly contained.
They're domesticated,
but they have dark meat like a wild pig does cause they're hitting every like
their shit.
Everything that she does,
everything they can get their hands on.
It's a hard scrabble life.
They do the wild pig ham,
the Blackfoot hog.
They eat acorns.
That's why that funding issue does.
I got something up the refrigerator back there.
Yeah.
My buddy brought him back.
Chris Ryan,
Dr Chris Ryan brought it back from Spain.
Cuts him,
cut me off some snow.
It's a,
it's like Prosciutto,
the best preacher in the world.
Yeah.
We could have a fight companion with pig pursuit has it'd be smacking into,
I'm going to have to get some again,
just animated gifs.
If you poppin peanuts in your mouth and shout and chewing,
chewing bars.
All of us,
all of us are guilty.
We didn't drink any wine is what we did and that's why it was a good,
good pull it.
No,
my wife,
I'm afraid.
I'm the wide master and I must reserve the white for after the five combatants.
So sometimes we just get a little hammered.
We'll hammer.
Well I can get you going man.
I'm a little ridiculous.
This is a non drunk podcast.
Yeah.
Was a noon podcast.
We're responsible.
We're all parents.
Good cause for dads is our new Sitcom.
It's called for dads escape fo dads.
We don't want to buy.
It's,
we don't know what's going on.
The only place where we can be ourself because we live with women,
with women and by ourselves with me and we talk about fighting had nausea,
you know,
you do.
You get all those four bitches to move into a house together and take care of
the kids and we'll move into the house right next door and just have FICA Pena's
every day can come along and go,
this place smells like man,
Eh.
They come over and pick up your sockets.
This yard,
it's Brandon and Brian.
You left pizza on the fucking counter.
Sorry.
We're like,
sorry.
This is way she lived over in the world,
Bro.
You gotta live by their rules.
You got to fucking,
you got to not use those special towels.
Yeah.
Geez.
The towel that's hanging is a towel.
It's a fucking towel.
Of course it yesterday of towel.
This is a different kind of task guys.
We sleep in the same bed but it's guys,
but
I got a morning hard on you guys should this and that.
Scared Brennan grab it.
Let's see how big your hand is.
I might dig
down man.
My prostate's big cause I'm older so I'm dribbling.
You guys edit,
you'll see you shoot.
One of the things I think about Brian,
whenever we go on these hunting trips,
it's like it's all dudes were all like in Rainelle and his crew,
who are this the fucking salt of the earth or hanging around just laughing.
I'm like,
this is what we're supposed to do.
It's true when men are supposed to do is get in these groups and they go out and
they list,
leave the women alone.
The women talk shit about you while you're gone.
And then the enough time passes where they miss you and you come back and they
meet you at the door and your hug.
This is traditional.
That's right.
This is when you're all on top of each other all the time.
It just wears on each other.
Right.
And we have so much fun trips are all one big comedy show.
Well it's all men being men.
Yeah.
It's saying things that will get you in real trouble.
People heard.
Don't you feel like you're doing that in general though when you're doing your
comedy and hang out with your friends and companions and shit,
but when you're in the middle of Alaska,
like we're literally miles from anything including other animals by the way.
Uh,
you just ended up,
there's something that happens to you where you just want to say the most
outrageous shit cause he's like,
how can I one up Joe,
now I'm going to say something outrageous that's gonna even shock me.
No,
I guess we could do that dinner though.
Right?
But there's a difference when you're in the woods and you're doing this.
And me and Brian are like specifically geared for like fucking with each other
and those kinds of situations.
And I also know that what he's saying,
he doesn't mean,
and he's joking and I'm expecting him to take it to another place that's even
more fucked up and it just keeps going.
And it,
when we were in Montana the first time,
it was literally five days of gay jokes and a few with a few wife beating jokes
thrown in there and just took a shit choke fuck jokes.
And I took a shit,
took a shit and Joe took a fucking,
he put a flag in it.
I made an aluminum foil
in my shit.
Terrible shit to a terrible mountain.
Do you?
Don't bury your shelf.
Buried them in the middle of Lou did.
That place sucks.
I'm sorry about the shit that I had boot.
Nobody's going to be like,
God damn it in the Missouri breaks worth nothing dries out there.
You take a shit,
you ruin the landscape.
Fuck,
we'll use a mustard poop.
You were supposed to take it and put it in bags and most of the time we did
that.
Occasionally you're supposed to like protect the environment.
You don't want a bunch of shit.
Especially your shit after you've been eating that dehydrated meals and food and
the it comes in a pouch.
Aw.
Can't just bury it,
but you can burry it.
That's probably the best.
Or you can put a flag in it.
You buried the message that says Brian was here.
Well he shit all log and then I put a aluminum foil.
I'm seeing if I have it in here.
Aluminum foil flag in the log.
Yeah,
it was good times.
Yeah.
And by the way,
we are,
we were in our late forties ago.
Taxpaying adults,
anecdotal often with opinions.
You guys could do that like once a year.
I do it.
I could do it once a month.
Once a month.
I mean if I'm with him,
which just say that the fun of being haunted and once a month,
one being an idiot,
being out there and being miserable,
but kind of having fun at the same time.
There's something about it that makes it brings out in many ways the best of
you.
You have a good time even though you're miserable,
it's bonding.
Like you,
you're miserable and you're cold and you're wet,
but you're laughing your ass off.
Like when we finally made that fire and uh,
I mean,
well if you've ever enjoyed a fire that much,
we were rained on for like five days in a row and then we finally got a dry
night and we've got a bunch of the guys from campus find is many small pieces of
dry wood as we could.
We stacked it on top of each other and started lighting.
Fritos,
you are wet.
Joe.
Joe didn't bring the proper reindeer.
He was basically wet,
including the sleeping bag was wet the whole time.
And I remember we were in that 10 and I was looking at you and you were,
you were just talking,
but you were shaking shivering ships.
Your lips are going blue and they were just chilling back and
he's got huge lips but,
and you just kept talking and it was just,
it was just,
guess what?
It's the morning.
Our body temperature is low.
We're wet,
we're cold as fuck,
and we're going to be cold until we start walking.
Yeah.
Well,
once you start walking,
even though you're wet,
you're wearing wool clothes.
That's the thing about those first light.
Merino wool.
Even when you're wet,
how many days?
We were there for six days.
Yeah.
It was awesome though,
man.
Even though it sucked,
I think about the memory and it was awesome.
Yeah,
and then also the landscape was awesome.
It's just,
it's so wild there,
man.
Do that shit every Saturday at Runyon or something.
She'd be surprised though,
because you do,
the memory brings you back.
That's Turkey Hunt and look at that.
Look at how handsome I am.
I mean we are.
That was a,
that was in northern California.
That was like,
that was hilarious because we would go Turkey hunting during the day and then
grind and I would go to the finest restaurants at night because it was all these
amazing restaurants in Napa.
These fucking guys wanted to pretend they were camping.
So they went back to this airbnb house and made like fucking burgers from like,
I go,
come on guys.
I saw it in me.
Let's go eat.
Let's get wine.
Yes.
They didn't want to do it.
Cars up down for that.
Yes,
we drink the best wine eight the world.
Brian and I went to this fucking insane restaurant and I had this,
this short rib Rizzo know that I still jerk off to this day.
That sounds fucking Rad.
Like shape,
like shaved squash,
like oh God.
Cam like a pumpkin.
He takes two jumpers.
Sodo and like this rich like burgundy salt,
like a red wine sauce for the short ribs.
Oh,
I'm getting nostalgic right now.
Looking at these pictures
are mine hunting.
I just did one without you.
It wasn't as fun.
I,
well,
you know,
nearly as firing me.
Well I couldn't.
You know how to shoot a bow and arrow.
You fuck fuck.
That's right you.
But you could be there for moral support and it's kind of cold.
Josie,
I could have practiced and I could've,
I have held your hips while your shot.
You could do that.
I could have gotten your ear while you were drawing and I could've gone control
your breathing,
control your breathing,
control your,
but this is going to feel like what it is and it is what it is.
You know,
the more spectacular thing about it or the,
the weirdest thing of as being introduced to the world of public land.
That's one of the weirdest things about a hunting that I didn't anticipate.
What do you mean?
We own human beings that live in the United States and pay taxes.
We own enormous chunks of land that are public land that you can go hiking on
and rafting and you can go fishing and hunting if you have the proper tags and
licenses and it's not like this anywhere in the world.
Like we have this incredible resource.
We have all this public land that you can go and explore on and it's all
amazing.
There's so much amazing wilderness.
Where were you?
We were in Nevada in the high country desert.
What is that like five hours outside of Reno,
you go to Reno and then he'd go five hours into the desert.
Hot as fuck drove five hours.
Mule deer.
And what's that topography like?
What's it's alien man?
It's amazing.
These hills that are covered in sage and then these patches of small Mahogany
and and like um,
like desert trees and it just springs.
He got to find,
you find springs and the animals generally go near the springs and the springs
are really easy to fine cause you look at him,
this like sort of grayish,
greenish,
dry landscape.
And then you see these lush patches and then you go to those lush green patches
and that's where their springs and that's where a lot of animals tend to
congregate.
It's fucking amazing.
You allowed to use a drone to hunt?
No.
In most states they're starting to stop that.
But in some states,
yet some states it's still illegal.
And most of them what they're doing is they're using them to spot me.
It's,
it's super controversial like what you're allowed to do and what you're not
allowed to do.
Like,
like in Nova.
Yeah.
And like in Nevada where we were,
you're allowed to use walkie talkies.
So you could tell me were a deer is and it's totally legal.
But if we're in Montana,
that would be illegal.
How the fuck they gonna tell?
Well they,
you don't just don't,
you know,
if you have goals,
you really should follow them because the rules that are in place,
if it's so fucking hard,
if you are bone Arrow hunting to close in on a mule deer,
it's so hard that they're like,
yeah,
go ahead.
Use a walkie talkie.
Yeah,
bitchy.
Go ahead.
But Montana's like,
yeah,
but what if a guy has a rifle?
We have to kind of have universal rules across the bat.
And if you have a rifle in Montana,
you're dealing with much more wooded area.
You could kind of pinpoint where the animal is.
Maybe a little bit better.
Maybe it's a little too much.
And Montana is like a real traditional state.
Like they don't even allow lighted Arrow knocks.
You can't have a light on your Arrow site on your both site.
You can have a light walkie talkie law because they don't want you to be able to
have a bunch of friends.
Like here's,
here's a perfect example.
Like one state,
like Arizona is famous for allowing the use of,
um,
of walkie talkies and allowing the use of a electronics.
So,
and there's certain tags that are really hard to draw.
Like there's a unit called 13 B and it's called the strip.
It's a strip between Utah and Arizona and it's so coveted in so cherished
because the animals are enormous and it's really well matched.
Like pull up Arizona Strip mule,
deer buck.
These things look like elk.
Like some of them are like 270 inches.
Enormous fucking when they measure like each time.
And you know what else was huge?
Columbus,
Ohio,
Ohio has giant.
Okay,
why a lot of the Midwest us.
But my point is this one area,
because it's so difficult to get a tag there.
They'll a guy,
we'll see what it is.
It Paul.
Oh My god,
this is a deer.
By the way.
This isn't an elk.
These are enormous,
dear.
Oh.
So once in a lifetime tag to be able to hunt.
One of these animals is literally once in a lifetime because they make sure that
very few people can hunt them so they can keep the populations very strong
credit,
credible,
because the genetics are so powerful.
So when a guy gets a tag,
like for a deer like this,
what they,
this is,
if you get three 13 B tag for Arizona,
you want to get a deer like this.
So these people literally will bring 20 of their friends.
This is a once in a lifetime thing.
So your buddies come and help out and they all get around on these different
points and they glass meaning they set up tripods,
they put on binoculars and spotting scopes,
and they locate the animal and then everyone's coordinating.
So like,
you know,
you got to go a hundred yards down,
go down there.
He's at the bottom of the canyon and then the other at the other entities,
like we've got an eye on him out here.
He's not coming this way.
We've got about it gets,
it's still,
it's still difficult because first of all,
it's impossible to get a tag,
but for these people,
it's like so important that they capitalized on this one opportunity that
they're ever going to have in their life to hunt in this area.
Look at that.
It's very controversial.
Wouldn't be hunting because some people say,
oh,
you should be able to have one guy who's communicating with you,
and some people say you shouldn't ever be able to communicate.
It's always going to be a debate,
but with these guys,
the way it's set up,
you can,
you could have a bunch of people,
so I can tell you that even if you have a lot of people,
I'm sure a lot of people leave that hunting ground empty hand.
Of course,
the rate of success is super low and that's an elk.
Look at that rack.
You know,
they're using drones to keep the rhino safe and African though those phones yet
to make sure the poachers end to find poachers.
Now the drones are beasts down there.
Well,
it's helping with that.
We're going to have to have some drone rules over the next few years because
they're going to get bigger and better and quicker and easier.
Smaller and more stealthy.
Yeah.
They're going to look like bugs.
Yup.
You got it.
Will you know you're gonna be able to spy on your ex girlfriend by floating one
right in her house when she opens her door and she's not even gonna know,
just kill everything.
It's not even gonna know.
They might have silent solar powered Tesla.
Tesla made drones.
All right kids.
That's it.
You leave it on that.
I guess my amount of Tesla,
I've got to get home,
but a level three of you and just come see me in New York.
Everybody.
Where are you going to be in New York?
Brian?
Count.
I'll be at the Gotham comedy club.
You're going to be there too.
Damn.
Yes I am.
I'm doing that in November.
I'm there September 16th and 17th Friday,
Saturday May.
Where are you?
September 22nd though,
but yeah,
we are in Oxnard,
California.
Wrong.
I know.
Dead.
No,
I know.
We are in San Jose.
San Jose.
Glad you're paying attention.
That's what I meant.
I meant that in Oxnard.
Uh,
not till October.
That's right.
Yeah.
Did you just share was,
how was that new?
Love it.
He lives what's called liberty live.
Yeah,
it was great.
Nice Edge.
September 11th Edi.
Next Sunday,
the 22nd get tickets.
See and live ubi,
official.com check out the Ebi eight countdown show on Youtube.
Oh Shit.
Everybody.
All right.
That's it,
folks.
See you soon.
Bye.
All right,
kids.